Casting you fuck,
you don't know what you're talking about.
Your stream is producers, not
the, not the best product,
but it's free of shit has just as
good as like tri quarters like those,
those tri castors. So things are expensive
as shit. Everything on the Internet.
Now I bought a Garmin navigation anymore.
You can download wave for free
and it's just as good when I yeah,
you can get a lot of free shit now.
That's just as good.
Like this pod cast bitches,
we ain't charging the Joe
Rogan experience, however,
is sponsored by some awesome companies.
But I'll tell you what,
we're not sponsored by Grillo's pickles.
It's past that shit over here.
All people say to me,
a QP took you to boot.
Why is this okay? We've got a problem
here because I'm not seeing anything.
Let me refresh this and see if
it shows where broadcasting,
but I'm not seeing it.
Oh, there's the image.
Okay. Um, Grillo's pickles is not
a sponsor. They're just nice guys.
We met them when I was doing
a zookeeper with Kevin James.
We were,
we were in the Commons and they had this
cart where they were selling pickles.
I'm like,
who the fuck is selling pickles?
Like what a weird thing to sell and I
thought they were going to be like those
seven 11 pickles.
You know you get them in a bag of
pickle juice and they're mildly good.
These things are fucking ridiculously
good. Yeah, they're fresh or hot.
They got car lucky. They have garlic in
them that you see like they have like,
look at this.
Can you see this online folks?
This is like fucking swamp grass in here.
See we,
these mother fuckers are doing
Voodoo with these pickles.
This is big ass slices of garlic and
as big as slices of Haba narrows and
Jalapenos in there and then there's fresh
pickles and these mother fuckers are
ridiculous. No one's paying me for
this. This is 100% for bonanza for them.
It must be great. Josh Joel fucking
glove. I ate a whole container of these.
I panic when I get low and they send them
to you from Boston to me from Boston.
They ship them to me. Are panic
when I get low, I fucking panic.
They're the best fucking snack
ever. Guilt free. 100% guilt-free.
Yeah. Cause they're eating cucumbers.
The vegetables. I sit in front of the TV,
I fucking smack the fuck out
on these things and I don't,
I don't feel bad. Yeah.
Cause I'll fucking,
I'll down a whole bag of popcorn kettle
corn or I'll fuck up a whole bag of uh,
like cheesy popcorn,
popcorn with cheese on it or
potato chips with vinegar and salt.
I'll fuck up a whole bag and then I'll
feel like a loser and I'll wait an hour
and a half and I'll lift weights. I
will, I'm like, I can't be a pussy.
I can't just go to bed on that. Like a
fat slob cause that's step one to death.
So I'll make sure I do dead lifts and
an hour and a half when the potato chips
of have dropped down. Good
for you. But I eat these.
I don't feel guilty if you're in Boston,
you're first of all you're fucked because
it gets too cold there in the winter
and that Shit's ridiculous.
And the women are to kind of tell
it to high school up there, man,
it's not the place. It's not the place.
It's beautiful place. I loved it,
but you know what?
It made me me.
I'm a wrestling and suck and weight in
that winter. Yeah. Oh, it was good times.
I did that as well. Walking around like
a rail in that, you know the zero. Yeah.
Excuse me. I'm in the middle
of a podcast. My kids,
ladies and gentleman,
this is why I have to get a studio.
This is why my kids are crazy.
The shine the children in
the background is fantastic.
There's always like a new home or just
say, this is not really an emergency.
My dollies, I fell off. We're
going to have to glue it back on.
Is it going to be okay? I'm pretty sure
we can glue. It becomes a huge issue.
I have. I have fake tea
every, every morning now.
Tea Parties or parties
yesterday with both of them.
My daughter's got to milk the cow to
actually drink it too. You have to do it.
I have to blow on it first. I'm like,
God, I gotta go. She's like, wait,
you have to blow my, come on. Yeah, but
it's important to play with the man.
I enjoy. Well, let's get to it
through the fucking podcast first.
This is not a commercial. Okay.
We'll put this as a commercial.
The Grillo's pickles things.
This is 100% for free just because I
love them and their pickles are fucking
fantastic and the nice people.
Anyway,
the Joe Rogan experience podcast is
actually sponsored. Where's that phone?
Give me that phone man.
Oh, Samsung Galaxy three.
I got a galaxy three from teen and this
is going to be one of our new sponsors.
They, uh, they run 10 runs on the
Verizon or the sprint network rather.
So they have excellent service
and there's no contracts and,
and they have some dope phones,
including the Samsung Galaxy three.
So what does ting ting is
out a new mobile company.
It's like there's alternative routes.
They rent space on a sprint. The way,
I don't,
I don't want to speak out of school
because I haven't read their literature.
But essentially what it is is
they run on the sprint network,
they rent the sprint network, but they
take a different wrist in sprint does.
They, they rent a service and
they say, listen, you know,
we'll charge you by what you use.
You can quit when you want and you're,
you have no contract.
So it's a way like better deal
for someone who doesn't, you know,
you might try this and go, you know,
when a fuck droids I need an iPhone,
I've got to get to at t and
t I got to quit. If you quit,
you don't have to worry about like losing,
you know,
like a ton of money or having to
pay some contract breaking fee.
And if you use less on one month,
you actually get credit for it
on the next month. So yeah, it's,
it's a really good company.
It's a good deal. And you know,
cause they're on sprint,
it'll be good service,
but that they're not an
official sponsor yet.
So this is another non
commercial commercial.
But I finally got ahold of one of these
Samsung Galaxy threes. I had that there.
There was good as it gets. Yeah, it's
supposed to be like a giant iPhone.
I need to find out. You know what,
the operating system, just like,
I need to read band hates these
fucking things, but does he,
he doesn't like droids
there's and believe in him,
but to me it's just computer
people are really into that.
They fall into different camps.
Apples, you only way they get crazy.
Well you want to get an apple, get a piece
of shit. I stick with Dell. You're like,
God, I'm not in your ward dude.
I have no dog in that fight.
He says blankety weird
statements. He like, okay,
I'm into guys fucking dummy dumped dumb.
We are actually legitimately sponsored,
only buy on it.
That's o n n I t and a on as a company
that provides me with a alpha brain.
And um, I uh, I'm a part
owner in the company when,
so when you support on it, you actually
support this podcast and support me.
Why did I become a part owner? Because
I 100% believe in what they're doing.
The ethics are absolutely perfect.
What they're trying to do is sell you
the best shit possible for the lowest
price point and make it as clean as
possible so that no one feels ripped off.
So when you buy 30 pills,
there is a 100% money back guarantee.
You don't even have to return the
product. You just go, this isn't for me.
I've read things online by intelligent
people that are claiming that it's a
placebo. I don't know how everybody's
body works. Everybody's different.
Everybody's body has a different reaction
to caffeine and alcohol and cigarettes
and vitamins. I don't
know. Yeah, we'd for sure.
I don't know how your
body reacts to things,
but what I do know is that all of the
nutrients inside of Alpha brain have been
proven to have a positive effect
on human cognitive function.
And there are studies behind that,
and we're actually putting together
our own study. It's about to go live.
We've established a protocol and it will
be a double blind placebo study at a
legitimate university to show
everyone that there is a, uh,
a noticeable measurable benefit and
taking nutrients. I 100% believe this.
I've been a big fan of vitamins for a
long time. I'm very sensitive to my body,
especially when apples touch yourself.
Very sensitive to my body. Um,
I know when I smell, I know when I
feel good. I know the difference.
When I take fish oil and I don't fish.
Take Vishal,
I always talk about this for Jujitsu,
if you take Jujitsu,
there's two things that are musts,
acid office and fish oil, acidophilus,
healthy bacteria,
very important case staff away.
So important ringworm everything and
colds as well because when you come in
contact with colds, a lot of it is
through your hands touching things. Well,
what as a dot Phyllis is,
is this yeast and milk culture is
a very aggressive culture and it's,
it's a mutually compatible with your body
so you can take it and you're fine and
it's all over your skin. Well when it
comes in contact with some, some bugs,
it just gangs up on,
it beats the fuck out of the disease.
It's like having an army.
It's like having a healthy army.
That Kombucha that you
grab from my fridge, I,
you never find my fridge unless it's got
combustion. It's never not stocked with.
It's got great. It's got a
mushroom bacteria. Yes. It's,
it's got healthy things that
you take in your body. Well,
we have to realize that our bodies
are not just your body. It's not just,
you know, hey, I'm Brian Kelly and
this is in my blood and my wall. Yeah.
There's a lot of stuff in there.
And the other thing that they are
finding is that essentially your body is,
is like almost like an
ecosystem in its own with,
it's made up mostly of organisms,
most microbes and good
bacteria and bad bacteria.
And when you keep the balance
of bad bacteria in relation
to the good versus the
bad, that's how you maintain
good health. Absolutely.
And Science and a lot of scientists now
are working on cultivating the bacteria
in your body so that you have,
you know,
only good bacteria or you manage it
accordingly and that's the future in some
circles of, of, of how you're going
to be even healthier in the future.
What we're trying to provide it on it is
all things that have a positive effect
on the human body.
All of our supplements like Alpha brain,
shroom tech is another one.
Shroom tech is based on the quarter subs
mushroom and which has been shown to
have a positive effect on your
ability to simulate oxygen.
And this was actually discovered by high
altitude herders. They found that there,
yeah,
that their animals were
eating these mushrooms and
they were having more energy,
that we're moving around more and
there was a noticeable difference.
So they started eating them. Yeah.
And their, the way they grow them,
it's fucking crazy. It's a fungus. They
actually have to grow it on caterpillars.
It's insane. It's insane. It's a,
it's weird and it's really
hard to cultivate and it's
really fucking expensive.
But if you use a code name, Rogan, you
get 10% off any and all the supplements,
everything we sell you is the
best shit you can buy everything.
It might not be the cheapest,
but it's the cheapest we can sell
it and it's the best shit possible.
Like hemp force protein,
hemp protein is the easiest
protein for your body to digest.
It's much easier than whey
protein. I like way, you know,
I love like muscle milk
and stuff like that,
but it fucking lights my asshole up
like a canon. It's got a lot. I, I,
it's hard to digest. Sometimes way is a,
it's, it's not as nearly as easy as hemp.
And there's some good hemp,
there's like Manitoba Harvest.
I've used that stuff before
that's like a chocolate ham,
but it cannot fuck with him. Force
him. Force tastes so much better.
And one of the reasons is because
we use the best quality hemp hearts.
We use hemp hearts.
The best quality you can get.
It's so hard to get that you can
only buy 50 pounds of it a day.
So we have to put a new order in
every day because he's hemp hearts.
We can't grow them in America
because of this contin government.
And even though Vermont and two
other states have passed laws,
allowing them to grow the non
psychoactive at all, I won't allow,
the federal government said they would
come in and arrest people and ignore
unequivocal terms.
We'll know what clearly they said clearly.
They said they would put people in jail.
It's fucking horrible.
It's horrible to think about that.
The you would arrest someone for growing
as a client to be involved in enforcing.
Exactly. So the marijuana laws
have nothing to do with hemp,
which is really crazy because you
literally can't get high off him.
That's another thing that people get
up. Keep asking me. If you eat this,
a hemp force, am I going to test
positive for THC at work? No. No,
you absolutely will not. However,
if you eat a poppy seed Bagel,
you'll test positive for heroin something
a lot of times, I don't know. Oh,
100% and that's what I tell about
Olympic athletes and stuff. Yeah,
well that's happened to people that
have had a heroin tests at work.
This happened to people who eat
a lot of poppy seed bangles.
You test positive for the same metabolite.
Um,
so you don't have to worry about that
with hemp force, which is so crazy.
We have to buy this
shit in another country.
We would on it would be
willing to grow it in America,
hire American farmers to grow it and,
and give people jobs and help
the American economy. But no,
this and government with its horrible
corruption and deep rooted ties to
pharmaceutical companies literally won't
even let anything close to marijuana.
And if you want to read it,
how closely tied they are to
the pharmaceutical companies.
Pick up a book called the China
study by t Colin Campbell,
a phd who was on the inside of,
of,
of all this stuff and was on the national
board of scientists. And it is a,
he's a nutritional scientist
out of Cornell University.
It is a fascinating book,
an expo say on how industry has
hijacked skus than how you eat.
Why the school lunch program? 28
million counting children. Uh,
eat what the dairy industry,
the meat industry and the sugar lobby
wants them to eat cause it's big business
and why children are suffering from
diabetes and a host of other chronic
illnesses.
Don't take my word for it.
Look at a credible scientist and
real data to support what I'm saying.
It is fascinating.
This is a guy on the inside who knows all
the scientists in the academics who've
been, who've been, who,
who can take money from the same
corporation they're doing research for.
The point is we're on a fucking pirate
ship. So that's why hemp is expensive.
It's the really the only reason it's a,
it's a high quality food that we should
be able to grow and grow in this country.
We also sell, we just started
selling exercise equipment. Oh, hemp.
Hemp force also has maca
in it and raw cocoa.
Raw Cocoa is a very powerful antioxidant
and Maca is a stimulates testosterone
growth son gets that libido on
kid just tossed around as a band.
Yeah, it's going to be banned
eventually. They're gonna want,
they're gonna want the
world filled with pussy.
Do you really want horny men
running through your neighborhood?
You've never worked on a little dude.
We're going to have to be talk about
this as soon as this commercial's over
kettlebells. That's what I'm
all about, ladies and gentlemen.
And we sell a host of kettlebells in
packages at [inaudible] dot com and again,
these bitches aren't cheap,
but they're the best quality.
You can get as cheap as we can sell them.
They are essentially canon
balls with handles on them.
They're fucking fantastic
there. Troy. Kettle bells,
they're the best we could buy.
They have the perfect dimensions there.
They're fucking so durable.
You buy them once you have
exercise equipment for life,
they literally are a lifelong tool.
They will never break their fucking
iron cannon ball with a handle on it.
Where is it? It's nice to get
a kettle ball exercises online.
Youtube is the best free.
Youtube is free. We're going to,
we're making a Kettlebell DVD that you
could work out along with me with Steve
Maxwell Cause uh, Steve Maxwell who was
a black belt in Brazilian Jujitsu, uh,
as well as a, um, uh,
like world renowned Kettle Bell Instructor
and fitness instructor and just a
brilliant guy.
I love having conversations with them
about fitness because I always learned
something new.
I've been working with him for years and
we make little videos on my cell phone.
I can show me the exercise and we'll do
a video. Like he, he, he got me through,
he's got like a bunch of exercises
that he's programmed for me.
One of them was just a full body weight
exercise routine where I did nothing but
body weight. It's something I could do
in a hotel with a towel over a door.
Like he's really into like that.
You can,
you can do a full workout and it's a
brutal bodyweight workout. It's fucking,
you know,
one legged squats and shit like that
and one arm pushups and crazy shit. Oh,
Hindu pushups, Hindu
squats. And it's a ruthless,
ruthless workout that you could do
in a little room, you know, push,
push a chair to the side and you've
got a gym in your hotel room to kill
yourself actually.
So we're going to make d DVDs and a
and have them also for sale and on it.
So Steve Maxwell's in which
I'm very excited about
because I wanted to make sure
that if I'm doing a video, I don't
want to fuck anything. Buddies backup.
I want us to shut up,
fucking do everything wrong,
my monkey ass and then have you do it,
you know, so, uh, we'll have that soon.
All right. And I'm
going to record the, uh,
the Joe Rogan a soundtrack in the backlog.
What's the soundtrack?
Well, this, well, this is
the podcast about the start.
Now you use the code name Brogan,
get 10% off any and all supplements at
[inaudible] dot com including the hemp
force and the kettle bells
in the battle ropes. However,
we were selling those
bitches as cheap as we can.
Battle ropes is the cheapest you can find
on the Internet and a battle ropes or
in another awesome caveman style.
Manly motherfucking workout.
Go to [inaudible] Dot Com oh and and it
hit it.
I was just gonna say,
what do you do when you're single
Joe Rogan's show he got shot.
You got to get Deb down. Three
players. I don't have the whole song,
but I'm certainly forces.
Hello. Toll Role Gum.
He is your friend Joe Rogan.
He is the man until Rogan.
He's got the best damn podcast
in the lamb. He's got a thick,
short neck and a wide
face and very expressive,
very expressive eyes.
He's gonna go home moms short legs and um,
hi Todd. How son? A burrow. Snakes
ball roll back a payroll of snakes.
Bull.
Rebecca.
Not to mention the fact that his lower
extremities when they more at home on a
mew who,
who's Joe Rogan, his, your friend.
And Joe Rogan is the man.
He's so Rogan.
He's got the best damn podcast.
Thank you very much.
Everybody know if I should
help you and it, that's how I,
that's how I had that. It's
emotional. It's all, I can't you guys.
Maybe I'll add some more verses,
but that's all I've got for now.
I was a shambles.
That stupid song in the shower.
You sing that song? I was
like, yeah, I was a while.
When I woke up the morning I was like, I'm
bored. And I was like, in June he goes,
mom, friend, his name was Joe Rogan
and I started breaking down your body.
You might have like the worst sense
of beat and rhythm ever do it.
I'm the terrible thing is you're
talking about, I have no words.
I am the police. How many police
put that to music so I can,
so I can just revel in,
play it on a loop in my car.
I would be a terrible musician,
dude.
Why are we thinking about my body
when you by yourself. That's crazy.
I was soaking myself down. Yeah. And
I was touching myself. I don't know.
It makes me feel weird. Mixed feeling.
I was feeling I wanted to be as thick.
And why didn't you know?
Really? How about it?
He stuck in why I can't go north to south.
So I go east to west here thing.
I'm meant to be carrying bricks and
pills. You were always, yeah. Yeah.
This is thinking about you.
Even when I'm back in the day,
you were always working out and you had
just, you had big hands, big hands, long.
Your arms are long. Legs are short, arms
are long. Well, my legs aren't short.
My upper body short. Oh, that's
okay. It's actually, yeah,
very weird. Yeah. It's built
to bear to Harry rocks.
Up Hills. Sicilian stone masons have
to say, and what happened to me,
I'm built for dance.
Some of these trucks,
all the rocks and I'm built
for dance fucking employees.
I'm built to gesture and emote.
Well,
that's one of the things I
think I like about kettle bells.
I feel like I'm working hard.
I just
put in a fucking hard kettlebell
workout, man. It's like you're, you know,
you're really going to war.
You're fighting something.
It's not just like doing a bench. I've
never done a really hard kettlebell work,
but maybe you'll take me through. How
dare you. You're in my house. Yeah.
Maybe I'll take before I feed you the
grass fed steaks that I got some grass fed
steaks.
You to a high right now,
but we'll do it after a
little too high to workout.
It's the best time to work
out. Fuck yeah, I don't smoke.
You don't smoke enough wheat.
That's the problem.
You've got to get
comfortable with the waves.
It's like if you don't know how to surf
and you get on a board in the wave hits
you, you're going to fall on your
ass. Why? And you're like, no, no, no.
You just don't know how
to handle the wave yet.
You've got to learn how to ride the
weed waves the whole life. Someone's,
when someone's high all the time,
they can just handle being high.
They can handle being hot,
talking to a cop and then he ended up
being high buying tickets at the movie
theater. They're used to the boat they
used to the front of the waves. Man,
these that experience, I like that
you lift weights when you're high,
you feel your muscles may fuel your
tissue. You do feel way more intense.
Everything pops stretches better.
It feels great when you
stretch high stretching highs.
It's like when you were all
high two letters. Oh yeah.
I do Jujitsu high all the time.
Whenever you gave me,
I feel I have good energy right now.
Sativa.
It's called sage cities
sativa, Sativa. It's uh,
it's all um, positive and
energetic. It's not like a,
I've never done standup.
Highlight this. Yes, you have.
We got your high ones before I
show. That's true. Oh, that's right.
That was fucking,
that's right.
That was at the Ice House and I started
talking about saving a baby that was
trapped under a smart car show,
Shanghai before every show. Man.
For real fuck around. Why fuck
around lately on stage, I've been,
I don't know if this ever happens to you,
but I'll get up like just a winkling have
an idea and I just start following it
on stage and sometimes it just starts
forming itself. Other times you're like,
where am I going? What are you doing
this weekend? You got gigs? Yeah.
I'm going to be in a, actually,
I'm glad you remind me.
I'll be in Vegas at the Paris at the
Paris was a great new room and I'll be
there Thursday, Friday, Saturday
come out, it's court court,
Mcfarland's Corp and gallons place
and quarter Paris and it's great.
And the court will be middling
for me and I can't wait man.
I had a great time in Schaumburg.
Thanks everybody is Schomburg and thanks
to Joe Rogan because a lot of people
came out because they listen to this and
um, it was, it was, it was amazing, man.
I love, I love those crowds. I love
that room is great room. I love Chicago.
There's so nice. Yeah, they're
great. They're just polite
people. They're better.
They're better than us. I love the
way you said that you looked down.
Now they're better than us. They are
better than us. They're real people.
They have to deal with this all winter,
which soft, softer on the belly.
There's something to be said about, about
having to deal with the winter. They,
they say that the, the, the people
in the north developed faster and,
and technologically because they had to
get ready for the winter because they,
the winner was something you
had to develop a sense of time.
You have to figure out how to harvest
store food and all the things that come
with that.
And it required a higher level of
technology and a higher level of sort of
planning and, and, and
in some ways, uh, uh, uh,
discipline because criminals are
way smarter on the East Coast. Yeah.
Well they're organized.
It's called the mafia because
those aren't the smart ones.
The Russians are the smart ones. The
Russians, Chinese, you don't know. Yeah.
The Russians and the Chinese
keep their fucking miles calls.
The Italians start reality
shows like mob wives.
You imagine if a Russian
chick tried to start a mob,
wives show they would kill that bitch.
But these weak ass guineas are letting
these fucking dumb broads go on TV and
spelled all their nonsense,
basically indicting them
when an entire life of crime.
You know what you're getting into when
you entering this life. Oh really?
So you're admitting your husband's a
fucking criminal on TV. You dumb cunt.
Is that what you're doing?
What you're doing?
I don't want to you if you are
in a criminal empire, okay.
If you're involved in something like that,
you can't go on a reality show
and just make light of it.
Like it's no big deal to be fucking mob
wife because I guarantee you there's
some shit in that guy's past that
he's denied and then he would say,
none of them.
I'm not a lifetime criminal and this,
you got a wife on TV to your real guy.
You're a real mafia guy.
Your wife doesn't know a damn thing.
They found, they found the Chinese,
the head of the Chinese triads,
they said in New York and you know what
he'd been doing for 15 years selling, uh,
so that at one of those pushcarts
Jesus Christ, that was his cover.
She's squaring off that they're willing
to take it to the sodas. Not fucking,
it's warm. Gimme Your fucking
mic. Cold Soda. Let's go.
He's the head of a try and he was dealing
with that everyday. That's hilarious.
Ran The triad when they had that
whole Gadi thing going on in New York.
I remember going, what is going on?
They can't arrest the mafia guy.
Like this main montage, the
Teflon. Don, where's this?
I remember thinking like met and spent
a lot of time with his lawyer. Really?
What's his name? Can't remember his
name now. It's make this buffer,
buffer counselor, counselor,
counselor, something like Katar.
No, what other Bruce Cutler.
Cutler maybe. Anyway,
he looks like a big gorilla. I thought
he was an Italian guy. He was Jewish.
I'm Jewish. I'm from Brooklyn. I don't
believe in violence, but I was a wrestler.
He was a wrestler and he never lost,
he said,
but he was at really great guy and Oh,
what is his name? What is his name?
We got to Google. Okay. Um,
but he was such a good guy and we
had so much fun and I'm really it.
Bruce Cutler or Bruce? I don't
remember. Uh, yeah, he's a great guy.
He's got a great sense
of humor. Um, and, uh,
and he was just talking about
how defending somebody, you know,
is that they're going to send you
with for a thousand years. I'm,
I'm going to defend you. I'm going to
do everything I can. And uh, you know,
but he says it. He said, yeah,
Bruce Cutler, we said about
God, he said, he said, I've,
I've, I've, uh,
I have defended some very formidable
men and that is the one guy who really
lived what he spoke,
what he said. You know,
I was into ever tell you the story
about being in little Italy in 91,
let's call it, and uh, it might even
be, yeah, something like that. It was,
I think it was even met 90, and it
was early and I was at, and he had a,
I can't remember the
name of his social club,
but it was right near a
restaurant called Cafe Sorrento.
And we used to go there and right next
door was the social club. Oh, come on,
what's called mall. And I'll never
forget, and that's where God,
he and his boys used to hang out.
And you'd see these just rough
looking dudes with earpieces and,
and they'd stayed,
the car would pull up and stuff.
And I remember I was eating and the
outdoor cafe was with this girl and I saw
these two dudes in suits with open shirts,
raven,
Raven night shows and,
and Catholics went to was right next door.
And I remember seeing,
um,
these two just giant men walking
out on their way clearly to do,
I could smell it, I could see
it clearly to do something bad,
clearly do something like,
you know,
and I remember looking at how big and
formidable they were and how they were
basically professional
knuckle knuckle breakers.
And I thought to myself that that would
put the fear of God in you, that that's,
you better be ready for guys
who are going to, you know,
because the cops are gonna come and then
they're going to grow and those guys
are going to wait. They're going
to come back. That's right.
That's what their job is to get that
done. That's right. They go like this,
they go, hello and I
say, have a good evening.
And then they come back and the whole
place is burned down. See you soon.
Fuckface Susan Saturday and
mother for me. Right. Yeah.
It's a very scary thing to
have. Uh, organized crime.
Well corporations in technology
actually actually um,
took a big bite out of organized crime.
Couldn't shake down local businesses
anymore cause they weren't,
they were all cs and things.
It's interesting,
the Raven Night Social Club is now
a shoe store. Oh Wow. Yep. Wow.
It's shoes and purse and the, and the way
they brought down, brought down, got it.
Ever hear the story.
The guy who used to run the Raven night
social club managed it and he was the
guy who took care of cleaning the tables.
Everything else.
They send a cop in there. This
beautiful woman, she was a cop.
She banged them on the
table and as he was having,
as he was banging on the table,
she put a mic under the table
and that's how, and that,
that is how she took one.
She took one for the team,
took some fos guy,
took some cock bang,
put it under there and grouper
brought the whole thing down.
I wonder if she came.
That's a good question.
One of she was like so like
turned on by the fucking scandal.
She was a sexual patriot.
Wow. And absent she'll,
patriot is a new distinction there it is.
I've never heard of a sexual patriot
before. Oh by the way everybody,
thank you for making man thoughts with
Brian Cowen number nine yesterday.
Thanks to the Joe Rogan podcast.
Cause I know a lot of you guys are
just going over from here to there.
I mean that's Kinda crazy but love you.
I started talking about
the 10 minute podcasts.
I started talking about my
podcast the next day, the
next day. He's like, dude, my,
my, my, my buddy was like, you're
number 13 dude on iTunes. I was like,
have you ever seen the youtube comments
whenever we request people to go look at
a video? No. It's hilariously whatever.
Like, I've recommended like an
Allman brothers song the other day,
and you go to the song now
and for the first three pages,
it's just says like powerful Joe Rogan,
uh,
all of garden butthole. That's
awesome. Yeah, it's hilarious.
Joe Rogan sent me. Yeah, it's ridiculous.
What, what do you think is the, well,
I mean, your podcast is to become
a bit of a phenomenon and you know,
as long as I've known you,
the one thing I know about you
is that you've never ever lied.
You're just an authentic dude and you, for
better, for worse, for better, for worse,
you were always the guy. And when you
were young, it was so inconvenient.
If you didn't like somebody at
that, in that circle, you'd be like,
I don't know if I'm like, you, I
like it. So there it is. I mean,
it was basically that,
are they figured out real quick that
you just had a problem with you?
We're willing to tolerate some really
ridiculous people in your life. And, uh,
I loved you and I'd be hanging around
with you and I'd see all these problems in
your life.
And it drove me crazy because it wasn't
just that I didn't like this guy.
I was mad that this guy was
wasting your time with nonsense,
these idiots and liars and frauds and
dummies and you didn't want to hurt their
feelings. So you accommodated them.
It's right and I was offended.
I was offended by them.
I was offended by them for being so weak.
The run this week game and then you were
accepting this week game so they didn't
grow.
Do you know,
do you know a lot of young people
listen to this and one of we know what I
figured out after a while and why don't,
why don't do that anymore?
Why don't suffer fools
anymore is because when you,
when you suffer fools like that,
what you're doing is actually taking
your time away from and from real people.
People's do design at the time.
Exactly. You know who are not imposters.
It's not good for them either.
The fools.
If you let a fool before they have to be
a four by saying that you know the, the,
that's who they are and you just accept
that they're never going to grow.
And I don't know if they can grow.
I don't know what their
potential for growth is,
but we're not going to fucking
find out if you tolerate them.
You can't do it because you
lose all your energy. It takes,
it's actually a form of high tech
procrastination. If I think back on it,
I think a lot of it was just pie tech
procrastination. We do as human beings,
astonishing things to ensure
our own failure or to at
least ensure that we don't
realize our potential tension.
And we do crazy things like have
a family with three kids that we,
and with a woman we don't like or,
or,
or take a job that we have to take because
we got a hold down this massive nut
we create for ourselves when
what we should be doing.
And actually it's turning pro. He talks
about this a lot. Pressfield, Pressfield,
you know, and the war of art and the war
of art. It was so we do these things,
it's very hard and I always tell people,
I say,
if you really want to try
an exercise, just, just it.
Ask yourself if you couldn't fail,
if you couldn't fail,
you can get anything you want.
Just make a list of what you
really want in technicolor and,
and see what it does to you. It's
hard to face up to it. You know,
a lot of people have like competing like
notions in their own mind about money.
You know,
they,
there was psychiatry talking about how
you have all these weird things like
money, money buys. You can't
buy you happiness. It's the
root of all evil, right?
But we all want money.
So we within our own mind,
we had these major conflicts of interest.
Whenever you bring up the word money
because it ha it conjures up both negative
and positive images in us.
That's interesting to me because you and
I know that if you make enough money,
you can do a lot of good with it.
You can make a difference with it.
So everybody should be trying in some
way to be, it's not just about money,
but trying to be the best they can be.
Cause you'll make a difference.
But I think within ourselves,
part of the human problem and
something you have to face it,
but as you get older is the fact that
there are a lot of contradictions within
your own mind because they'd been
given to you. You know? Um, it's,
it's really hard sometimes to just have
because you have to actually think you
deserve it.
And most of us are conditioned to be
guilty about having too much, you know?
Yeah. Well there's a lot of people in this
country that feel like it's okay to be
angry you because you're successful.
There's a lot of people that will sell
it go fucking rouge as lots less in this
country than other countries.
And I'll tell you why.
And one of the strengths of our country
is this. And George will has a great,
he gave a great speech
about this. Um, the, the,
the great thing about America
is that all of us out there, no,
and I hope we're not losing side of
this because in some ways you can get
cynical about the way
this world is wired now.
But at the bottom line is a lot of
Americans know, I may be poor today,
but if I do the right thing,
I might be rich tomorrow.
And that sense of potential in the
American character is what drives this
economy. It's why we're so innovative.
That's all well and good as an ideal.
But the real problem has nothing to
do with America. An ideal. The real
problem has to do with weakness of
character and people not liking people who
were successful. Yes. You know, I had
a friend who will remain nameless,
but he's a very nice guy and he's
a comedian. He's a sort of a,
a bit of the self hating nebbishy
type. And he said, good, it's you.
You're always doing this with your
body. Like why? You know why, why?
Why have your why have all these
muscles? Why, why being shaped like,
why are you so concentrated
on that? Like for real, I go,
if I gave you a pill and that pill,
all you could do,
you could take this pill and you all of
a sudden you're, you're a super athlete.
You're a person who's unlike 99.9%
of the people who run the street.
You're a martial arts expert.
You could choke people.
You could kick the shit out of them if
you wanted to. You can defend yourself.
Wouldn't you take that pill? And
he goes, yeah, I would. I go, well,
that pill is just hard work, right? If you
do hard work, you'd become that. And See,
I did it without a pill.
Consistency. So it's the same thing.
It's like there's nothing
wrong with being in shape.
The only thing that's
wrong with being a chain,
because if you're not in shape and you
see a guys in shape and you see a woman
react to that guy and shape in
a very sexually attracted way,
it makes you feel uncomfortable.
So you want to pull the goal back.
You want to make the game easier.
You want,
you don't want to compete
with this guy. You know, and,
and it starts with like I always
tell people, you know, but first,
first ask yourself,
be honest with yourself man.
Sit there alone and ask
yourself what you really want.
I mean ask you some detail then don't go.
Don't like if you have to get your
phd or something ridiculous. Don't,
don't look at the top of the mountain.
Just take an action every day.
I don't care what it is,
one little action and,
and that's what I do like just take,
just keep taking. It's like working out.
Show up. I don't give a shit
if you start with five minutes,
when you show up to you develop momentum,
that's it.
When you start to develop a momentum,
the human being relies a lot on momentum.
It's a weird habit.
We're obese of habit and momentum.
And when you that have a habit
of working out all the time,
if I don't work out for a few days, I feel
super uncomfortable. I don't feel good.
You have to, you have to exercise
on a regular, regular basis.
And when you do that, you develop
momentum. When I write a lot, I'm writing,
I get on a momentous sort of a wave and I,
I feel good about it and it becomes
a part of my habit. That's Ya.
You'll have to do is make, give yourself
positive habits, positive habits.
These accesses the habit, by the way.
You're right. Yeah. Be Proud. Be Proud of,
of getting work done. Be happy that
you're getting work done. I mean that,
that is what you do.
You know a lot of people also remember
you surround yourself with a lot of
people who don't want happy for you.
Then I actually your friends,
but what they are is their comfort.
They're creatures of comfort
and not actually your friends.
And I think it's important. Sometimes you
got to change your fucking gang change.
We're one of the reasons why you and I
were such good friends when I met you.
It's like you, first of all, you were the,
for the closest guy to me I've
ever met in my life. I was like,
Holy Shit.
Here's this guy who's like exactly
like me and you required nothing.
You like you, you had no like what? Man,
you're not going to come to my
birthday party and you weren't.
There was not no creepy
dummy shit in there.
And I had just gotten out of a friendship
where I had to kick a guy out of my
life because I was friends
with them when I was broke.
And then once I got on television he
got really fucking jealous and he said a
lot of dumb shit. I asked him
not to give away my phone number.
I said I have two phone numbers because
I've always had like a media phone and
in the regular phone because when you do
media like you, like you do radio shows,
they have to call you back.
And I want to have a phone where if I
pull it out of the wall I don't give a
fuck who calls, you know, so I have that
phone. So I said, just do me a favor.
Your friend who by the way just
cut out of a mental institution,
would you do me a favor?
And just give him my other phone.
He doesn't fucking care about you,
man. Just cause you, you're on TV.
Your friend just got out of a mental
institution. He's fucking crazy.
All I'm asking is if you're going to
bring this crazy guy into my life by
connection given the media
phone and he went in the school,
you think you're such a fucking bad
ass cause you're on TV. I'm like,
what is this?
What are you even talking about man?
I'm asking you not to give your crazy
friend like number. That's it. Yeah,
that's it. And all of a sudden it has
to become some attack on, you know,
and I'm on my success. And it was
a, it wasn't even a big success,
it was just part on a sitcom. But you
remind them of what they're not doing.
And a lot of people go into
this notion of scarcity,
this idea that there's only
a certain amount of the pie.
And if my somebody else is doing well,
I'm not going to do with,
I'm not even thinking that all they're
thinking about is themselves and not
looking at us as giant
picture of resources.
All they're doing is just like being a
baby. All of a sudden is what about me?
I had a friend who got apart and as he
got a part, you've got a part in a sitcom.
His girlfriend started crying.
I'm never gonna get anything.
What about me? Like this guy just got
a part on a sitcom. He was so happy.
He was like, I can't believe I got
it. I nailed the audition. I got it.
I worked my ass.
Man.
Woo.
Don't date actresses, actresses.
It's part of the song.
Very strict. No head shots, policies. It's
very always steal that. Cause I, I uh,
I went through my head shots
phase and I, uh, I just stopped
doing it. Yeah. You, uh,
you learn, you know, you
don't want to date anybody.
It's just fucked up as you are. That's
very bottom line. I don't want to do it.
I can manage my fucked up in this. I don't
want to introduce yours and the other,
the downstage. I was talking
about my daughter and I was like,
I just don't want her
to date a guy like me.
That sounds so I got to play a
character for the next 15 years.
So she imprints on and that's
somebody different. Yeah.
Well my friends had a of good do if the
start date and girls or started dating
boys. I'm like, guess what? Girls like
boys. That's it. Boys like girls too.
The only thing you can do is this.
Here's my philosophy. It's good. It's,
they're supposed to like girls and girls
are supposed to like boys tell them
with the right values and a good mind,
they're gonna make their mistakes. That's,
that's all you can it afraid of
their child. Make sure if they're,
if they're looking up to a yogurt
like Kim Kardashian and just give an
alternative, they're not going to
look up to that dummy. It's real.
If you don't fuck your kids up,
if you raised them like they're friends
and you talk to them and communicate
with them,
they're not going to be attracted to
something as stupid as a life of Kim Dash
watching you. I'm watching you with
your first daughter and you were,
you would talk to her like an adult and
when I would talk to him and like this,
cause I didn't,
I didn't know anything about play.
I play with my kids but I talked to them
and I think kids know a lot more than
you think. They know. You know, I mean
I, I'm, I'm down to play princess.
I'm down to pretend Santa Claus is real.
I'm down for pretend.
But when it comes to emotions,
one of the first things I do whenever
I catch them doing something wrong,
like they hit each other
or yell at each other,
I always tell them that I did the same
thing always like one of them bit her
sister the other day I go a bit, a little
girl when I was five I got in trouble.
But some girl in her hand, she was
sticking her hand on my mouse. I'm like,
fuck you bitch. I better. Yeah.
So I told her after first,
after the first three times you put
your hand in your mouth on my mouth and
watching her little four year old eyes
like look at me and realized that I used
to be dumb and did a lot of like,
it wasn't just her daddy
and wasn't just an adult.
At one point in time I was a little
child as well, just like her.
And I was telling her like,
I very remember biting this
girl and it was very traumatic.
I shouldn't have done it.
And the girl was mad at her mom was
mad and I felt like an idiot, you know?
And her mom's like, why didn't you just
slugger? You didn't have to bite her.
And I'm like, I'm sorry.
It was just felt like fuck.
I mean it didn't even break skin
or anything. It was just so dark.
The worst thing from me, the worst times
in my life, I can realize, remember,
was when I was embarrassed. Do
you tell your kids this? Really,
I haven't told my daughter that it
was old enough now to understand
anytime there's any sort of an issue.
I think that's one of the
most important things.
The same with my stepdaughter was an old,
older boy.
He's done the same thing with her. Um,
she's not, I mean say stepdaughter,
she's my daughter. And um, and when,
well that's why I communicate what,
but what I communicate,
whether it's the same thing,
it's always gotta be
that the human beings,
you're giving them the benefit of the
doubt actually they have the same mind is
we do, they don't have context.
That's exactly what children,
and when you bring them into your world
like that and you communicate with them
their, then they'll bring you
into their thoughts as well.
It's amazing how much my four year old
just opens up and talks to me about how
she feels about things. What bothers
her. And do you think that you have a,
I was just talking about this with the,
I just recorded something with Jay Moore
on my podcast and I asked him if he had
a primary cra question that
runs through his mind every day.
Do you think you wake up with a
primary question? No. You don't have,
you don't have one overriding question.
No. Join Myself. That's, I don't know.
I think this is a journey. I just think
this is a ride. Absolutely. Look, it is,
it's temporary. It's not going to last. I
just want to enjoy myself. I want to be,
uh, uh, amongst friends and have a good
time. Have a good time doing my standup,
doing my work.
I have a good time doing Jujitsu,
hanging out with my boys at 10th planet
and John John Machado's having a good
time driving around, listening to music,
being nice to people. Yeah. I feel like,
you know,
we're all a little too small and this
giant universe to take ourselves too
serious. There's no benefit in it.
There's no benefit and self, grand jury.
There's the, the benefit is in friendship.
The benefit is in fun. Laughter. Can I,
I'm so psyched about you coming over here.
Like we talked about this,
our families are together.
Uh, Brian's wife's here. Um,
we have, uh, the kids here.
I've got steaks.
We're going to play some music,
listen to some music and drink some wine.
That's what life's about.
That's what life is about. Having
fun. I say that to you. I said,
we are going to mark our lives by the
number of times we laughed at each other
and we're silly and, and we're, we're,
we're just surprising and shocking each
other stats, but it's about Stan Ho.
Ba and I were on the phone the other day
and he was drunk and, uh, and he's like,
you know, I could quit standup but I
couldn't quit standups. He goes, I can't.
He goes, I don't need to do
comedy anymore. He goes by that.
I never want to stop hanging
out with comics cause you know,
he and I were just on the phone.
We're just laughing and talking
shit and laughing and laughing.
He called me. He was listening to the
Jamie podcast, Jamie Kilstein podcast.
In a, in a, in a van filled with
other people, like it was on,
on tour and he called me, it
sounded like a comedy club. He goes,
I just want to tell you,
we're listening to you right now
and everybody has something to say.
And then new,
like he holds up the phone and all the
comics and the vantage screaming and
cheering and applauding.
Jamie Kilstein had said some crazy shit
about tosh shouldn't have said that.
Rape Joke. And it was like he
went captain feminist on people,
so standup call and then I called them
back and we're just laughing and he's,
he feels like he's self so fun.
That's the kind of human beings
you're supposed to be in contact with.
Joey D is every time I'm hanging out with
their original, what a stamp on life.
That guys, he's just great. I mean he
just, he looks over at UFC and I'm,
I'm sitting like literally like six,
10 chairs away and he goes,
he just leaves him in. There's no
drama, no drama. And everybody's like,
what the fuck is that guy saying?
I was like, no drama, no drama.
We would do it at the end of the
world show with Joey Diaz, Doug, Stan,
hope me and god,
and a band called honey honey.
I'll be in December 21st,
2012 in Hollywood and it's going to be a,
at the Wiltern theater.
Come onstage as you again last.
Yelp is also coming to the
ice house this Friday night.
So if you're coming to the ice house,
we got chose the ice house. It's me,
Joey Diaz and Ari Shaffir
tonight and tomorrow night. Oh,
Doug. Stan helps or not tonight
and tomorrow. What am I retarded?
Today's Wednesday.
I didn't even know what day it is.
I wou Friday night and
Saturday night, sorry. Um,
at the Ice House and Friday nights. Dan
Hope's going to be here. I wish I could.
I would've come after that. I met
Stan Health and I'm a big, yeah,
I'd love to meet him. He's a great
guy. He's the best. I don't important.
He's so important to me.
He's like,
he's a real guy really doing it.
He's refreshing and he's 100% legit.
He's a 100% legit,
hilarious headliner comedian who's
just really into continuing to do that.
I'll be occasionally, reluctantly,
he's, he's, he's a little real deal man.
I was talking about Jay more today and uh,
and he, I said, yeah. I said, what's your,
what's your definition of heaven? And
I said, to be honest with you, man,
I think it's just being on
stage and doing stand up.
I don't think I'll ever take time off away
from me. He's like, what are you going,
when are you gonna Retire? I don't
think, I think I want to be don Rickles.
I'll be 85 years old.
The one fucking standup because we're not
just so much fun and what else could I
be doing finally?
Something else that's really fun.
You want to go skydiving when it, Nah,
I got, if people still want to listen,
I'll still be doing it. And when
they don't want to listen anymore,
when you're doing like half filled
shows and the people are barely,
then you're like, well maybe it
sounded packet in. But then again,
maybe it's time to go back to the drawing
board and come out with new stuff.
Well, it could be. Yeah, for sure. I mean,
it could be that it could be a lapse,
but for some people it's
the end. You know, there's a
lot of people that get fat,
get fat in the brain. They
have to, got to keep feeding.
I always tell like young comics,
I'm like, feed your brain.
It's important to read everything if
you can or as much as you can you you,
and keep asking yourself the next
question. It's how you stay dynamic.
It's how your material will grow and
it's how you will grow as a person.
You know,
one of the things I've been getting,
nothing but great feedback about
this podcast I did with my dad. Well,
my dad's 72 what my dad continues to do
and what I respect about him so much as
he continues to grow.
I watched the 72 year old guy taking
Italian and going to Italy for three weeks
and throwing himself into a town.
When the fuck is he going to use it?
Talions yet he doesn't care.
He takes it reading these obscure
things on quantum physics and stuff.
He's just always so because he enjoys it.
I think what people have to really,
the reason why that's shocking to people
is most people feel like there's a
destination.
Well,
I'm going to reach retirement and when
I reach retirement then I'm going to
change.
There is no,
there is just now there is just life
and you should think about the future,
but your primary concern should be now
it should be a life and what do you enjoy
doing? Do you enjoy learning things? Do
enjoy reading? Do you enjoy isolation?
Tanks are fucking hikes or workout
that stuff. And by the way,
here's something for people to say,
well I can't do that cause I got to put
money on food on the table for my kids.
You'll set a very,
very good example to your children.
If you're following your dream and
what you're supposed to be doing that
children pick up on,
that they can pick up on whether you're
you're doing drudgery or you're doing
something inspiring for yourself and
it'll make your household better.
In my opinion. That's easy
for me to say, by the way,
cause I'm not having to pay bills
all the time so I don't want to,
I don't want to be too disrespectful
that people who were actually trying to
just make some money and
figure their shit out,
but just keeping in the back
of your mind that you know,
just just find some people get an easy
ride in this life. We all know that.
Some people get really lucky and
they get an easy ride in this life,
but that doesn't usually last.
Most of the people would get an easy ride.
If they don't earn it, they wind
up fucking it up. That's true.
Almost always true and your ride is
different than anybody else's ride as my
ride is different from
anybody else's ride,
but you gotta except that instead of
being mad at other people's rides,
you got to only look at what you're dealt.
What is the hand your
dealt moved from there?
Don't worry about this guy who's fucking
rich prick. He's born in new floor.
Could Richo said it's nothing to judge
[inaudible] he's got all this money.
Could think she's or that
is not your concern. Okay,
that guy's got his own problems.
If you concentrate on him and hate on him,
that is wasted resources.
When you should be concentrating on is
what hand where you dealt, you know, well,
I'm not so good at math, but you know
why and I think I want to be a rapper.
Be a rapper. What? Concentrate on
yourself. Concentrate on one hand,
please remember also, this is so
important as I get older, this is,
there's no doubt about this.
Anybody who you admire who's really good
at something, whether it's to drums,
Jujitsu, math, whatever, please know this.
They've put in at least 10 years of really
hard work at, not always. Not always.
You know what I'm saying? Some people
are prodigies, but quick, but anything,
anything that you,
anything that you want to get good at,
you're going to have to put daily practice
into and should always do it for the
sake of the practice, not the result you
get. You get just as much like somebody,
somebody said, well I don't know about
the time I get my psychology degree.
I don't know if I get,
look, you're going to be,
while you're trying to get
your psychology degree,
you're going to be meeting people.
You want to be around who are dynamic
and interesting cause they're gonna be
doing the same thing you're doing.
So it's the fun starts almost right away.
Well it's,
people just get scared about longterm
goals and longterm commitments.
It's like, just keep working. You're
going to keep working anyway on something.
Right.
Are you just going to stop moving?
You're going to work on feeding yourself.
You're going to fucking move forward.
Tim Ferriss said something interesting
in his book. He goes, my goals,
I don't set these 10 year goals. I set
three month goals, six month goals,
nine month goals, 12 months goals
that that's a good way to do it.
You can get a lot done in three months.
So you know, just something simple.
I don't set any goals, you
know, never, never set goals.
I set objectives like as far as like what
I want to get done in days during the
day, but I, my goal is to be doing what I
wanted to do and I'm already doing that.
Oh yeah.
You've always thought I don't have any,
but you've always had very clear
notions. I'm talking to you, you'll go,
I remember you going on to start
my own TV show, my own TV channel.
I remember you saying that before
the podcast. Then you were like, Duh,
I'm going to do a podcast.
So you get these ideas and the difference
between you is that once you get an
idea like that,
like once you're into something,
whether it's a video game or a sport,
you're a,
you're a co Ku Cooper about it.
Fucking cuckoo. Like, I'm like,
what are you doing? He goes,
I just finished practicing quake for
15 hours. I fainted. I'm like, well,
how about I'll do it for an
hour and 15 minutes, 59 hours.
I fainted.
I didn't get any water.
That's you.
Well,
I grew up completely obsessed with
martial arts and that mindset of,
uh, the, the practice of martial
arts, which was defining for me,
let's look made me a human being.
It was the first thing I was ever
really good at. That became the,
the way I live my whole life and
live life like you're about to,
you're about to do the most dangerous
thing you could ever possibly imagine.
So you have to be obsessed with it to get
really good at it. I can't, not again,
like half ass something.
I get crazy.
But why do you think you would be good
at standup? Will you a class towns?
I didn't think I was kidding.
I didn't either.
I had a very specific idea that the
only people that laughed at me with the
people that were these sick fucks that
I trained with because those are the
people that taught my friend Ed
shorter and my friend Steve Graham,
Steve Graham is still one of
my best friends to this day.
When I was a little kid,
I used to make everybody laugh
at the top of my middle school.
I would do these impressions of my
instructor having sex with one of the
students. I never did any of that. I would
do it like, you know, in their, you know,
in the voice and with their accent shit
and it would be like one of our friends
was your intro. You're currently what? The
bluebells Korean. Your instructor? Yeah.
Well it wasn't,
that guy was another guy that actually
make fun of who is like more of an
assistant. My instructor was Korean
and he, we really respected him.
He's an amazing,
still an amazing guy,
one of the most influential
people in my life.
But I used to call fellow students as him
as a, as a chore. You know, my friends
would freak it. They'd be like,
Hi sir, how are you? Like why is he
calling me? He never called anybody.
We definitely have that in common that
we used to do impressions of people that
we knew. Yeah. That's what's
like the first kind of humor.
You recognize something goofy that
someone does and so you repeat it and I'm
putting my ridiculous scenarios,
but my first comedy came from high
school when I was in high school.
I was not a funny kid. I was a much
more troubled kid then I was funny,
but when, no, but I was an artist
and when no one was around,
I would go into Mr Homans class.
Mr. Holman was this really
wacky science teacher.
He's really fucking crazy and I knew how
to draw them all and I had a character
choice. Forget that. You're really good
drawer. I always forget that. Oh yeah.
I wanted to be a cartoon art.
I mean I'm a comic book artist.
I dedicated a lot of time and it was one
high school teacher that's sucked that
completely turned me off to it. I was
like, I can't do thank God for him. Yeah.
I think thank God for
that. Could be not, I mean,
I wouldn't have enjoyed being an artist.
A maybe I wouldn't have had to, you know,
be so, uh, I can't see you in a sitting
in a, at a drafting table all day.
Yeah. Maybe. Maybe. I don't
know. I don't know. I enjoyed
it though. I really enjoyed,
uh, illustrations. Um, uh, what
was my point? The, by the way,
illustrations are hypnotic, aren't
they? I mean, you can paint all day.
Like I know painters who set this guy,
I can't remember.
Damson ain't going to make me go off
traffic, Mr. Holman. Oh, okay. I'm sorry.
I just have to remember this.
So what I would do,
my first stab of humor was I would
draw pictures of this dude on
the board, like pictures of him,
but fuck. And other students or,
and then there's a guy named Mr. White
who's this really short dude who just got
back from Vietnam and he was
fucking crazy. And Mr. White,
I always drew him standing on
a chair or standing on a stool,
always drew him standing
on top of something.
And it was always screaming about nom, you
know, and uh, people would fucking how,
and I would put it on the chalkboard.
I got suspended because I
drew the Spanish teachers,
Penta teacher wore like a ton of, make
unbelievable amounts of makeup, like,
like a clown.
And then I drew her like her face with
all the makeup and then I drew a werewolf.
This is her without makeup and
fucking food was really good,
like fangs and slobbers I knew you were
really funny before I'd even seen you to
stand up. We were at the EOC and, and you
were sitting there and we were on a bus.
We were going, we were going back
being shuttled back something.
And this is like back in the day when
Randy couture, like had his first fight.
And I remember somebody goes, well,
Joe, what are you going to do tonight?
And he goes, and you were like, ah, I
think I'm going to get in a horse stance,
pushed my balls into my body and read
Nietzsche with a Bandanna around my head.
I was like,
yes, that's my favorite.
Kind of tends to wash downs.
There's a lot of dudes who
thought they could do that.
They don't think it pulled her balls
into their body too. And I used to try.
What are you talking about?
Just nobody was more obsessed.
The only person more
obsessed with martial arts.
Then you want me to put
your balls anywhere?
I can't do any movement with my balls.
You have to push him in.
Have you ever tried Tantra? You ever
tried like squeezing your, you're,
you're strengthening your core
muscles so you don't let any come out.
Does that work? Could you
make it stronger? They look,
it's what every guy does.
Who doesn't come right away. Okay. That's
what the fuck it's called maturity.
It's learning how to, I remember
being younger and just fucking say I,
the minute I smelled a girl, I'd
come. I'd be like, oh fucking God,
don't move out until late.
Isn't there some sort of a physiological
benefit to not orgasming and letting
your body like assimilate
the commonwell the essay,
the idea is that fighters,
the Samurai and the idea is that you can
boost your testosterone and apparently
the semen goes up your spine. Not True
at all. Not True at all. But believe me,
I believed it and used to say it for
years. I remember one time going, no,
we used to not,
we'd go with like two weeks without
jerking off or her getting late and would
just make you really feel a really
aggressive, I wouldn't do that.
I try to cook two district
science on fight science.
John Brenkus that that show,
they had guys not have sex for like a
week or something and they measured their
testosterone and then they had him like
calm and stuff and and there was no
difference.
They actually,
they actually have tested different
scientific fight sciences.
Not the fuck they're talking.
They don't have shown there's
a physiological difference,
but it only lasts for seven days.
After seven days it normalizes,
but for seven days you get a
higher level of testosterone.
It's like your body is like,
come on last chance to not be a pussy.
Let's go get some, c'mon,
c'mon, let's go get some.
I would think that your buddies crews
more testosterone to develop, build sperm,
but then again I'm not a fucking doctor.
I think it's also
to increase your competitive drive
in order to get some more pussy.
It's like your body recognizes
like that you haven't scored,
you haven't tried to reproduce so because
you haven't tried to reproduce it buys
like listen, let's fucking amp
this gorilla up, get them fired up,
ready to fight in case another
male comes along. Yeah, yeah.
Cause Cause Pussy scarce like
in Alaska or Boston. We're,
hopefully you and I will be. Yeah, we're
going to go, you're going to stop coming.
I'm coming. I'm coming hunting with
you and I and let's, let's, let's,
let's move this conversation over to,
to a little show called pig man.
Holy Shit. Talk about
that weaponry. By the way,
40 of them I've talked to Rinella
about an IA. Fucking hates that show.
Steven Ella, who's the guy who's the
host of meat eater, he helicopters, dude.
But he's a fair chase hunter.
I mean he's,
what he does is everything he does
is like stalking. He stalks his prey.
He doesn't wait and tree stand with a
pile of food lane this and then blow them.
Yeah. Oh, that's what we're
going, oh yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah. I'm coming. Oh,
he's an animal. You got to go. He's, he's
a great guy to a very intelligent guy.
He's not like you ship a girl, you know,
just look hood and you know, he's a,
he's a guy who, it's very sacred
to him. The whole, the whole,
like he went to a ranch once, they put
him in a tree stand and then he said,
well at 6:00 AM the deer come around.
Cause that's when we,
that's when the feeders opened up and
he realized there was electronic feeders
and it's like, I can't do
this. He wouldn't do it.
Whereas like Ted Nugent just fucking
launches arrows to those pitchy. I mean,
he literally target practice.
It's basically pigs.
It's actually domesticated
pigs that became feral. Well,
the pig man shows different.
I mean,
they're actually reading
the diary of a pastor. Yeah.
They have a real problem to like poor
people. Yes, yes, yes. They give the meat,
the needy families and it's good.
Neat. It's good. Well, it's wild pork.
It's delicious. But the, uh, the pigs
are a huge problem. They destroy crops.
They, uh, they run, they spread disease
and when they plant the seeds, they go in,
they route and they pull the seeds
out of the ground and eat the seeds.
Pigs will eat anything
and they're fucking huge.
So they have to radically cut them. So in
Texas it's legal to hunt them from God.
Does cons are, I don't, don't,
don't, don't, don't, don't, don't,
they just taken these fucking pigs
out while the pigs are running.
They're blowing their brains
out and the pigs do flips.
They killed 200 pigs plus
and 10 coyotes on one show.
I don't like,
I like coyotes.
Why would you like ladies good cause
you imagine if your baby was outside by
itself and the coyote came along.
How do you think,
how do you think that would work?
I don't even know.
Eat your baby every coyote near your baby.
Fuck himself.
Every Kyler that ever lived, I will
put a bullet in his fucking brand on,
I have great pack structures there.
Cons could fuck good hunters.
They beat and cock suckers.
Each and every one of them.
He make up anything to fucking kill,
to kill something like they babies.
I have proved leave a baby
alone. Coyote, coyote shovel.
We kill guy was called
baby killing baby killers.
That would be a satisfying show if you
just left a baby in a pen in the middle
of a street and the coyote is just come
around and you pick them off a sniper
rifles like, hey, deserves
it. This motherfuck was going
to eat the baby. The baby.
He was coming from the baby.
That's good.
I'm not in the coyotes.
I when your dog gets eaten
by a mountain lion, it's,
you have a different perspective
to me and hit you. Oh,
well I haven't had those
before. Yeah, pimples are great.
How about when you come home and one
of them killed the other one? Yeah,
that was a lot of fun.
Living Room was a puddle of blood.
The dog I told you to adopt,
she was actually the coffee table.
She was with Taylor,
a coffee table with tea.
She was a crocodile with a wood foot, long
legs. She was actually a crocodile. She,
she had a crocodile head and
she was clearly half crocodile,
sweetest dog about. I called.
He's like, Oh hey, this is one.
We were completely retarded. I
was like, Hey, get down here now.
I knew cause I couldn't adopt
him cause I had, I had a female,
she was so sweet and you're like,
I'm taking her there. Talk loved me.
There was a problem.
She loved me and she didn't want the
other dogs around because they would get
some of my loans. It's devastating
to, and I want you to fight.
She would fight to the death.
She was ready to fight to the death
over you petting. Did she ever do frank?
Only pimples to find other man like male
females. They fronted. Yeah, it's bad.
It was bad. I had to, I
had to put them both down.
Put Frank down to you get
tired of that shit. Right.
They both tried to kill each other.
It was horrible. I couldn't trust him.
Frank was like devastated after it was
over. She won. She beat the mail. She did.
Yup. Yeah, I left him for
dead. He was all fucked up.
He was in the hospital for
weeks. Yeah. Yeah. I never,
never thought that they would fight
and never thought the mail and a few,
I would separate the females,
but I never thought the mayor would
fight with a female and they fought.
You know what, they fought over the
pool guy. The Pool Guy came over to,
to clean the pool.
They started heading there pending
the poor guy pet one of them.
And she would fight frank if, if
uh, if she wasn't getting pet. Yeah.
Well she got fucked up man. When she was
in that pen or in the pound for awhile,
she was fucked up cause it was one of
those shelters where they didn't kill the
animal, they'd kept the animal around
and she was a fighting dog before that.
So she was a fighting dog and then all
of a sudden she's in the pound and then
all of a sudden she's at this house and
this guy is super sweet to her and loves
her and pet her and feed her food.
And she said,
these other dogs you got get
the fuck away. I don't want
to lose this. And it was,
should have been a great pet on by
our own but with the dog to on yours.
That's my experience.
I've always had,
I had two pit bulls for years and I've
had different sets of them and they just,
they just try to kill each other.
So good.
So good at getting like choking
them out off each other. But I just,
I they'd be fighting. And one time I
was on a date and piggy and my, my,
my uh, my fucking German German
Shepard, this working dog,
this bad ass fucking dog.
Okay.
That I like found this candidate and he
was like a long line of just nothing but
IPO and shuts on sport dogs.
This dog was a fucking wolf and by
the way had knock out drag out fights
with my dog piggy who is a pure pit bull
and a fight and dog and this dog held
her own no problem.
Meanwhile, I'm on a day me,
why would you let them find out
how and how do you know the day,
but there were two females. I want
you there when it happened. Oh, did,
what would happen was I'd come
home and it looked like Vietnam.
There'd be from everywhere blood
everywhere and they both be like,
and basically half dead. I'd rush
him to the vet, they'd be like,
that'll be $5,000.
I was like literally.
And so Nate fight sometimes I was
on a date, this girl is beautiful.
I remember and all of a sudden I just
here and I come running out and all,
I think his vet bills and they
just gotten out of their cones.
They used to walk around, they looked
like like Nixon and a baseball combined.
They literally just looked through jowls
and like stitches heal because what
you're saying is the role of swell up.
They had to shave him and then they'd
had these crazy stitches on the shaved
heads and necks and just swollen
with these jowls. It was awful.
The Giles because fees,
I'd have to train it.
They had the fucking pills and they were
in these cones and knocking everything
over and and so they get
in a fight and I was,
I was in the front yard for 20 minutes
trying to break them up cause I choke one
off. Then that one would
lose consciousness and then
the other one would get,
get a hold of it and then
I have to choke that one.
I'm dealing when we're getting kind of
20 minutes and my hands after and my
buddy came home, Bob, my buddy came home
and actually helped me break them up.
20 minutes later we're all fucked up.
My hands were so I,
I've been trying to like fight him so
badly. I was literally fun for my lift.
My hands couldn't, didn't work for for a
week. Go well, you're a pussy garden hose.
Uh,
what to separate some readily tried it
many times with my dogs and they were
like, ah, this is just cooling us
down in their mouth in their mouth.
Guess what? I talked to the trainer. He
goes, yeah, sometimes when you do that,
some dogs think that's the other dog is
doing it to them and so they fucking go
harder. Yeah. I had both of those don't
stick. It does matter because they'd be,
hold on. Remember when we went
to that guy's house who was a he?
He raised fighting. Pitbull's got one
of his puppies. The advertisement said,
this is how returning to an hour,
the advertisement said pit bulls.
There's no bullet. Our pit bread right
out of the box to Joe and I were like,
fighting dogs were in your
stupid like Reem, possibly fast,
accurate or some shit. And we're
just, we drive forever out there.
This guy's clearly a dog fighter slash
criminal slash whatever serial killer.
And I buy this dog even as a puppy,
wouldn't let go of your shoe laces.
And it really looked like a beagle. It
was really weird. It was a small dog.
So anyway, Brian can't take this
dog. He has a dog for a little while,
but it's just too much work. He's
really irresponsible. He doesn't.
So he gives a dog to his friend on the
farm and the, what does the dog do? Oh,
my friend called me and goes, hey bro,
your dog's no longer with us. I go, what?
He goes, yeah, I had to shoot it. I said,
why? He goes, oh, I don't know. Well,
let's see. Got Ahold of the baby cow.
Um, and then, uh, well no, I'm sorry.
Let me start again. It killed one
goat, then another goat and that go,
got caught up in, it's in, it's a rope.
And then started bleeding as it died
and then the cows started moving,
so the dog was like,
oh baby cow grabbed on that.
Then the de the neighbor did German
shepherd came out to protect the cow and
your dog broke both his legs.
Okay, it's pine legs and he said,
and I had a 55 pound dog that
looked like it was a hundred pounds.
It was so full of blood. It was just,
it was just so swollen with blood lust.
And he said, I'd never seen anything
like it. It couldn't get it off then.
Then after the German shepard goes
back to the cow, the baby cow.
So my buddy is trying to get it
off the baby cow and you have to,
you have a real responsibility when you
have a dog white though, those dogs,
they have too,
too much of a history of blood lust.
It's too hard for them to break. Pray
with people to hell on wheels with four,
four legs, great with people. You
just, if you have a dog like that,
you have to have it in a secure yard
and you have to be with it all the time
because otherwise you've got a monster.
You used them to hunt
boar or fight other dogs.
That's what pimples or the way that's
also pigman either see when they have them
that way they hold them down with the
dogs and then they cut the things.
It's not as crazy as the
watching the helicopter shit.
The helicopter thing was insane. The whole
show too. It's a whole half hour show.
Those are military style weapons.
It was like he was talking about
this before with a fully automatic,
when they hit the pigs and the pigs
are running and then they would do the
somersaults when they would like
brain. Um, and then the pigs,
pigs would go face down into the mud flip.
It's pretty fucking nuts, man. One pig,
they get to this one pig,
this giant boar and he fucking turns,
stops running and faces the helicopter,
like face down the helicopter.
Look at this motherfucker.
No Way.
They opened up on them and then
you see twitching kickin and shit.
They got him in the water.
Some of them went in the water nice.
And as her in the water,
don't, I don't talk to them.
You see their heads explode in the water.
Like this is the most carnage I have
ever seen on television and Mrs fucking
crazy to watch. You know, and
they're, they're fucking redneck.
So they're hooting and hollering
while pay 10 Nigga was like,
people think you should be illegal.
It should be illegal not to do it.
He's not exactly a middle of the road guy.
You don't kill a hundred pigs before
breakfast. You're a communist.
Just fucking shooting,
shooting at them out of this.
He was having a great time. Yeah. He
was like, if I always too many bullets,
Mrs Nugent will divorce me.
I was in Portugal and I saw a bull fight
and I was surprised at my own reaction.
I got really mad at how they
were treating that bull.
It made me feel really bad for the bull
and I was fucking actively rooting for
it to kill one of those guys.
Will they do and every now and then
they do the last one when the guy had to
kill it to shoot it,
you know, don't hurt it.
You've seen the horn with the
horn goes through the guys.
It's the crazy shit I've ever seen
in my life by the way. He, I think,
I believe he came back and fought like,
couldn't find any more,
but he fought a symbolic thing and
they were all cheering for him.
That's a bad ass.
And you want to read the definitive book
on bullfighting and it's really worth
it.
It's called death in the afternoon by um,
by Ernest timing the way it's an amazing
book. One guy had it through his mouth,
through his lower jaw and coming out
of this mouth. Yup. That those guys,
that's a bad ass. That's a bad ass
sport. I will. It's not a sport,
it's a crazy custom that you
custom vent to customers.
It's one of those things where
you could invent it today.
Do you know that the law in Spain,
you can,
you're not allowed to approach a
fighting bull on foot as a human being.
You have to approach it either on bicycle
or in a car or in a motorcycle. Why?
Because those fighting bulls are
smart enough. They can, they watch,
they watch how you move and
they learned very quickly.
They learned very quickly how so the first
time at Bullen inner ring sees a man.
It's the first time he's ever seen
a man on, on two feet. So he's not,
he does not know her moves. And a, there's
a whole thing that they do with that,
you know, that's important. You don't want
to have that uneven fight. Did you know,
you know,
they used to pit lions and also bears
on with both the short and bear baiting.
Guess, guess, guess who won every
one of those fights? Now the bowls,
I mean the bullets when they'd have
bulls against the lion or bulls against a
bear. Oh, bowls, bowls won every time.
Every time. Jesus. Every fucking time.
That's what Hemingway says. And the things
they, they, they, they, they, you're,
you're not, you're not fucking with,
uh, with, uh, they can lift the horse.
Speaking of which,
speaking of which,
did you see the youtube video of the bull
elephant that took the Mack truck got
under it with his tasks cause he was mad
at the Mack truck cause he fell out of
it and, and flip that shit over.
He fell out of the truck. Yeah,
they were trying to
load them on the truck,
I guess any fell out of
it and was like fuck this.
And he got under that Mack truck and
it's a real Mack truck and flipped it.
So turn to right over on its side.
So do you have any question of how strong,
and by the way,
they weighed 10,000 pounds.
A bull elephant weighs 10,000 pounds.
Ladies and Gentlemen,
Jesus Christ,
that's big enough for you.
I wonder who would win an elephant or
a bull and they're really smart and you
can train and do all kinds of crazy shit.
Well what's really smart about
them as the memory there,
they can see another elephant
which all looks the same to us,
but they don't see it for 10
years and then they run into it.
They run towards each other and hug
each other humans too. That's crazy man.
They know who you are and they
don't like certain people.
And I was in the San Diego
Zoo and I was watching them.
We paid extra to go and see them, how
they clean them and how they, you know,
teach them to bring, give them your,
have to say you can check them and stuff.
So they always have a barrier and
they're no joke. There's no a video.
Is there a um, it's gotta be yeah,
there's no, uh, it's not elephant.
I think flipping Mack truck or something.
Yeah, just put it on or flipping drunk.
Elephant versus drunk elephant.
I had to do it for a, I did it
for a true TV. They sent it to me.
Oh really? Well what is it
like, I'm assuming the DVD,
what is a true TV? Like a
show or something? I just
thing called world's dumbest.
Like world's dumbest. Oh, like one of
those things where you make fun of people,
comments, like make comments and stuff.
That stuff's on the way out. I think so,
yeah. TV something way out.
It's doing well though.
All those silly shows were on the way out.
Well,
what do you think is going to
replace the Internet? Yeah, yeah.
What's that mean for us?
It means that a podcast man,
thoughts at Brian Callan
I got to come up with,
that's what you're
calling it now, man. Man.
Thoughts change it from the council
to, ma'am, I can label it now. Oh,
we couldn't label it the
Brian [inaudible] show before.
This is more specific and it's kind of
what I think about I and I, and I'm,
you know, a man thoughts can
comprise a lot of different things,
but I'm trying to think
of what I'm going to,
I've got to make some tee shirts that
I would wear because I, you know,
I don't know. And not that I
didn't want to sell them, I just,
I'm just gonna like I'm
particular about my tee shirts.
How about just a little tiny
Cox over tiny ones? Let's see.
How about an image and the image? Really
cool image and image of Ronald Reagan,
but it's all made out of Cox. No, I
should've called my podcast Cox. Cox,
Dick.
Fuck,
that's a funny name for a
company called epic but doesn't,
um, someone has deke house
or something like that.
That's a Knoxville. Yeah. Yeah.
My Buddy, my buddy is doing a movie
with them. You can get away with that.
It's weird. Like I watched a CNN
the other day and there was a,
there's a band in Russia called Pussy
riot plus your ride and pussy riot broken
to a church. They got arrested, they got
arrested two years and yeah, they got,
they got sentenced to like two years
in jail and so everybody was having a
demonstration and they have these giant
signs that say free pussy riot and here
CNN,
it's showing this on CNN and I'm sitting
in front of the TV and these giant
signs say free pussy riot. And
I'm like, wow, that's hilarious.
Like what a weird loophole by the way
they, because they called it pussy riot.
Yeah, they have to, they
have to show what these guys,
that's blatantly obscene,
but it's on the news.
You know,
I was on a plane one time and the guy
started having an argument with the
stewardess before we took off.
All of a sudden he's just
saying he's not being a dick.
He's just saying some things like, well,
I'm not trying to cause a problem here.
You know, as I'm like, oh there's a guy,
I'm going to cause a riot, whatever.
And so next thing you know,
Marshall's or on the plane,
they take them off the plant
and what's going on? Well,
you're not allowed to use the
word riot on their certain,
we have certain trigger words
that we have to report. Uh,
because you could have been a terrorist.
We were trying to incite violence and
this is the kind of fucking bureaucratic
shit we deal with Jesus.
That's what happens when you had these
blanket laws and these absolute rules.
It's like fucking laws. It's too, too
much ridiculous how many pages the,
and I'm reading a book about it and I
think it's not a bad, not such a bad law.
There's a lot to like about it.
But you know how many pages
the Obamacare act as you know,
how many pages in the bill?
2,420 now who reads it?
Nobody. Thank you. That's a good
and especially you don't read.
You also don't read the clauses you
put in there. Who reads it? Uh, the,
the uh,
handful of reporters from the New York
Post who put out a book called landmark
that I'm reading now that really explains
what the Obamacare bill does and what
it means for us.
Listen that the thing about bills or the,
they'll sneak shit in that has almost
nothing to do with the name of the bill
just so that they can get it in and stuff
they've been trying to get in before.
My father said, the best thing
about it, my father said Washington,
he spent a lot of time on Capitol Hill
and he said, and this is a podcast.
He goes,
Lushington isn't the business of intent.
What that means is that you have a bill.
You want to create universal healthcare
or do you want to do whatever? You know,
these are good ideas. That
is the intention. Whatever.
What happens with a Goliath of Goliath,
like Waa, like the federal government,
is that there are so many vested interests
that find their way into that law.
So if you want me to vote for it,
that's fine.
You got to do something
for my constituency,
which means I've got to put this clause
in page 500 no one's gonna read it
anyway, don't worry about it. And before
you know it, that law that passed,
just like the marijuana laws,
there was a cottage industry that grows
up around those laws that have a vested
interest in keeping that law,
no matter whether it makes sense or not.
And that's what happens.
That's all of a sudden everybody's
drinking out of the government trough.
It comes down to very simple questions,
not Republican or Democrat.
This is why you say,
do you want the majority of our resources
in Washington under this massive roof?
Or does it make sense to spread
the resources somewhere else?
That's the big question,
and I happen to believe it's better to
keep resources out of Washington because
something that big can't help but create.
The real problem is you can't
untangle it. Now. It's so far.
Everybody's got their hand in.
Do you think, do you, how do you,
do you know the kind of tax breaks at
pharmaceutical companies get because they
own the FDA. Nobody else can break
into the drug business. You know why?
Because they own the scientist basically
that say Yay or nay. It takes, what,
12 or 13 years to get a drug patent?
You've got to go through all the tests
and they're, they're scientists. Go,
wait a minute, I've gotta be very
careful. They all take money from Pfizer,
et Cetera. Of course. Well, that's what
we were talking about before the podcast.
When it comes to our hump
force, a protein, it's,
we have to buy all of our hemp Canada
because the pharmaceutical companies have
bribed these fucking corrupt politicians
and made sure that it's illegal.
The federal federal government,
the state government voted for it and
the whole thing is supposed to be that
states are allowed to make their own laws.
The federal government is not supposed
to interfere with things along these
lines and they don't give a fuck. They'll
put you in jail if you just grow hemp,
which is a cousin of marijuana.
So let,
let me tell you another story
that's really interesting.
A friend of mine unfortunately
has pancreatic cancer.
I lost my other friend to it,
um, about three months ago,
but suddenly my friend's mom,
step mom has it and,
and she went to a doctor,
doctor gave her up chemo protocol.
Uh, just like with my friend was given
a chemo protocol and these are very good
doctors at a very well renowned hospital.
Um,
and the drugs costs a fortune. They
fight. It wasn't working that well.
They finally get into this,
the most famous,
the most famous doctor in the world
for pancreatic cancer at Ucla,
who's chemo protocol is a,
extends a lot of lives,
way beyond what you're supposed
to pancreatic cancer. He
said, basically, he said,
why are you on this? He said, he said, he
said, oh, I'm going to change your chemo,
um, and it's going to be a lot cheaper.
And they said, what do you mean? He said,
well, Eli Whitney put out a, uh,
something that costs $30,000 a year,
but it was the exact same thing as
the generic drug or whatever the,
the other chemo is that was $300 a year.
But Eli Whitney cleaned it was better.
So every doctor to this day,
I'm going to just follow me.
Every doctor to this day, um,
prescribes the Eli Whitney drug,
which is 30 times more expensive now
ready that Eli Whitney was challenged in
court. This doctor was one of the
people that say, it's, it's bullshit.
It is actually not as effective or not.
It's this one, which is much cheaper.
It's been around much longer.
It's just as effective.
Eli Whitney paid a fine for it.
It was worth it to Eli Whitney to pay
that fine and be dishonest because people
still stay. They're not following all
the tort laws. And then I follow him.
All the cases,
doctors,
all of the countries still prescribed
the Eli Whitney drug, even though,
even though it is not as good as the
one they could because they don't know
anybody better because they thought,
because Eli Whitney hired
this huge marketing campaign,
they thought that's the drug to do now
is the real problem is that nobody calls
him on it. That's right.
Well even if you do,
it costs them $20 million when they
make billions of dollars. So, so again,
these are massive companies that, that
don't really, that have, you know,
have basically hired who they want to
defend them and behave inappropriately.
I'm being, I'm not saying all big farmers
bad, I'm not saying everybody's there.
I think anytime you have four major
players and nobody can get in your fucking
industry, it's not good for
capitalism. It's not capitalism.
It's not a free market and it's not good
for our health and it's not good for
humanity as a whole. So there
the, the, that's what it is.
A real problem is how do you untangle it?
I mean,
there's so much money invested
in keeping Gov's only one way.
There's only one way. You've got
to starve government now. That's,
that's where the libertarian notion of
the Cato Institute basically says there's
responsible tax while you have to
have some taxes. Uh, but, but you,
the only way,
the only way we're ever going to get out
of this and not become western Europe
or worse is by,
by starving that that massive
Leviathan of resources. Yeah.
It is a problem when you create a bunch
of different government jobs, like,
you know,
there's a lot of people that rallied to
keep drugs illegal and one of them is
the unions that control guards,
prison guards, prison guard unions,
and they spend a lot of money from their
dues that they get from their workers
in order to keep drug laws the same.
Yeah.
Because that's what keeps them
working and what's not a philosophy.
It is self-interest. Yes, absolutely.
Self interest. And it's scary. That works.
It's scary that that would be allowed.
It's scary that that doesn't prompt.
I mean if you were an
insider trading guy knew,
just knew that some company was about to
go under and you got rid of your stock,
you'd go to fucking jail for that.
How come you can't go to jail for that?
How come you can't go to jail?
Because you are, you're, you're,
we are working to keep drug drug laws,
which everybody has shown a ridiculous
and most people believe are completely
ridiculous despite the massive
amount of propaganda that you do,
the way you do it. You, you, you get
yourself informed, get yourself informed,
get yourself organized.
And what happens is it takes a long time.
But pretty soon more and more people
start to say even about don't smoke weed.
This is a ridiculous law that's puts
so many people in jail for a long,
long time. Not only a taxpayer stance,
it's ruined families and everything else.
And,
uh,
when are we going to come to our senses
and realize that this should not be
illegal? And, and if you get enough
people behind the politician,
things start to change. The way you
do it though is through information.
And also I, I, my biggest problem
with government now is I feel,
I don't feel like I'm represented. I
just feel like, well, you're not, yeah,
the no one is anymore. I mean,
Obama's not even represented.
That's where special interests
are. That's, that's the problem.
They're supposed to cancel each other
out and they're not him as a human.
He's not represented.
I don't,
I don't think that guy has any say in
what the fuck happens. I really don't.
I think at the whole thing is completely
ridiculous. Without Congress. I mean,
you know, that's not
necessarily a bad, I mean,
but you don't necessarily want a
president to have too much power.
But the president sets
the agenda and the upper,
the president's responsibilities
always to do a, set the agenda.
But also also at the end of the day,
there are a lot of decisions where he's
presented with six different options
from six different interest groups and
he's got to make a decision and piss off
the other five. Yeah. But he's don't,
don't show in front of the camera, Bro.
That's disgusting. I know I got, I got,
I looked at that pickle and I was like,
I've got to have one. You can't do
that. You can't chew it. A microphone.
I know it's a little bit about the United
States won't, they won't tell you that.
It's probably Nsh redact this.
Uh, this William Binney is,
this guy was the NSA mathematician that
I was telling you about earlier. Um,
I've been obsessed with this guy
since we have had David Seaman on,
on Monday who was a congressional
candidate in Florida and this former NSA
director after nine 11. It, this
guy is a mathematician, you know,
um, one of the world's
renowned math mathematicians.
And what he did was create a
method for the government to,
uh, track dangerous individuals and
track people and, and, and, and book.
It turned out that the government
just used it openly on everyone.
And so he had to leave.
What a surprise.
They just decided to just literally
every phone call that you make this guy's
correct. And he is the guy
who fucking coated this shit.
If at every phone call that you make,
every text message you make,
every email you make goes into a database
and the government is in Utah building
a gigantic structure that will
literally house everything you do, say,
watch online, all your Internet
history, all that shit will be stored.
So if they ever want to just anything
they want to know about you, anything,
all they have to do is just pull
that. Shut up guys, if you want,
if you want to see somebody who really
sat around and thought about this stuff
and made the argument for why
that's not good, just youtube.
Milton Friedman. Well let's
before that, before that,
let's not get people confused.
Let's let's have people just check out
this story and the guy's name is Benny, B,
I n n,
e y,
and just go and read up on
this because just this alone,
it's going to fuck with your head and
what are they doing on some important
chopping wood? No, you hear that banging.
That's like someone's going
to drum fucking lives.
They think they could keep the kids from
banging on a drum in the hallway. No,
that's passive aggressive shit right there
buddy. That's what that is. They don't,
they don't like the fact that we're in
here having fun while they were out there
with the kid screaming.
No.
My mother used to do to get my father
to get back to my dad for years.
The household I grew up and my dad
would always travel and pain in the ass.
A lot of pressure and everything
else. My mother would, uh,
she'd always have part of the
house being worked on by man.
She just have part of the house always
not in repair and love that shit.
And my father basically in a bad mood,
it wouldn't know what it's like, oh,
I'm just having the kitchen redone
for the second time. They didn't know.
They love doing that. They love
it. They love like changing things
change. It's different. Like you
could, you could live in a log cabin.
Easy. Right. Me Too. I was in
college. It was three guys. Okay.
We didn't do the dishes for one month.
We had,
we had sprouts growing out of the
train for real. Okay. Finally did.
My girlfriend came over and she
was like so appalled. She goes,
I have to clean this. I can't
take it. I can't be around here.
And it smells like a greenhouse.
You know,
guys are guys are pigs folks.
So this binny guy, you gotta, you
gotta there's, there's youtube videos.
If you don't want to, uh,
to sit and read something.
National Security Agency,
whistleblower William Binney look
into that because this is, uh,
we, we, we've turned a corner
in our society where this is a,
it's an us against them.
Shit. It shouldn't be. And
remember also that every,
every totalitarian state and every state
that took control and power over people
used,
used national security and,
and domestic security and the
threat of terrorism, et Cetera,
as an excuse to take away your liberty.
It's so old schools.
You would think they've always been done.
I would think that that generation had
already moved out of business. You know,
I hate to think that the generation
coming up is going to go business as usual
because in my mind,
this generation,
the generation that's of age of adult age
now grew up with the Internet and that
generation is a different
group of human beings, vastly,
vastly different than anybody that
grew up in the sixties or seventies,
two completely different animals.
Thomas Jefferson said that the price
of freedom is eternal vigilance.
And part of, part of that,
what he's trying to say,
I think in a lot of ways is that you,
you may have your freedom,
but just know that it can be taken away
from you, uh, a lot faster than you think.
So you've gotta be very aware of the
signs read. That's why you read history,
cause you perspective and
you're real and you can,
you can recognize patterns and
destructive patterns and destructive.
But nobody saw this coming.
Nobody saw the ability to do this because
my mother saw it coming and there lots
of them monitoring their,
the NSA had mathematicians.
There are a lot of people that saw this
company I talked to about the fact that
it's already going on and let's,
William Binney had stepped out
and put his book by the way.
They broke into his house and stuck
a fucking gun in his face to the FBI,
came into his house and it,
and he never did anything wrong.
I didn't do anything wrong.
The whole thing is crazy.
We have a that just to really
fucking creepy, corrupt,
corrupt government being in
control of that which governs you,
which is what our country is based on,
has always been a very tenuous,
fragile arrangement and it's gotta be
defended every minute of the day and they
just need to stop. It
just needs, we need to,
we need to have new people in
government and with this new,
the new transparency that
exists because of the Internet,
you're going to be able
to still run things,
but you can't run things as corrupt
as they had been running forever and
everybody just wants to keep doing it.
Just like we were talking about
circumcision or bull fighting or anything.
That's ridiculous. It's old. It's in
nature. It's government. It's not people.
It's the bigger it becomes, the bigger
it becomes. Government needs a job.
And what does that job to either
tax or pass laws, both of them.
Of course the measures you,
you, you are going to have them.
The bigger government grows,
the more history shows you,
the bigger government grows,
the more, the more you know,
the more power they get
over you as an individual.
And that if just pick up
a history book, man. Yeah.
But is there a way to pull it
back? That's the question. That's,
that's the biggest question.
That's the biggest way to run things.
There's a way where
people pay a fair amount.
There's a way where we keep
a real military that keeps
us from ever being at the
mercy of an evil dictator
or an evil country.
Is there a way to do that and still
be a good country and still not be
completely and totally corrupt?
Yes.
Or is educate yourself and you and
you get informed, educate yourself.
That's not going to stop
them from running over.
You have to make you have that much power.
You've gotta
vote you gotta you gotta make noise.
Is Voting real well? If it is,
why did Ron Paul, I mean, why did he
lose two states that he clearly won?
Do you know that there's a,
there's plenty of evidence online and
this plenty of videos and show that show
in Maine and there was one other state
were Ron Paul should have one and they,
they, they hit it, they covered it.
I think that is that our
voting process is fairly,
it's actually compared to most parts of
the world compared to most parts of the
world. Did you see hacking democracy? No.
Hacking democracy makes it very strong
argument that the Bush Kerry election was
bought that if you watched the video,
it's a documentary on Hbo when they show
that they engineered in a third party
entrant into these voting machines and
the guy on the show Diebold had to change
their name and I'm Diebold anymore.
There's something else.
The guy on the show showed how he can
alter the results of, of any electric.
Doesn't surprise me. Yeah. So what do we
do? That's a good question. The Internet.
That's what I think.
I think the only thing that's gonna save
us is the young people coming up know
that this is a different world.
Know that this is a world that if
you're going to be a politician,
you're going to be completely,
you've got to be transparent,
everything's going to be transparent.
Every move you make and you can't get
away with doing things that we've done for
for decades and decades before.
It's a totally new game. Yeah.
That's the only thing that's,
it makes sense to me. You know,
the idea of overthrowing
the government like that,
is that a really fucking necessarily like
everybody's getting bonkers about that.
Throw the government, first of all,
it's, it's not a whole other thing.
There are ways to overthrow or change
the power structure or make it smaller.
What's also people
recognize in this country,
especially that we are the cops.
We are the military.
It's not the actual elite is these
creepy bankers and there's only a fuck on
small handful of them.
And if the military doesn't listen,
and if the government doesn't listen,
there's,
then it does take your phone away from
the table, please take your phone. Yeah.
It's making that [inaudible] if that's,
if we do that.
Yeah. So the phones, um,
especially a CDMA phones or a GSM phones,
there's a signal that picks up,
it's good. It does it in your car.
Sometimes they were doing your car
and you're staring up. He goes, oh,
that's my problem. That's your
phone, your phone. It's, it's,
it's at and t phones if you,
yeah.
If you had Verizon and
wouldn't do it as easily.
So it's sort of a different frequency
apparently. You know, CDMA is a,
an older frequency. The frequency of
the Verizon uses, but apparently it, uh,
it's different in that, uh,
it's, um, it's more robust.
It goes deeper into buildings.
But more countries have GSM.
Like my iPhone has both. So if I
go on the roads, Verizon phones,
so if I go on the road,
if I'm an England,
it'll work in England
because they only have GSM.
They gave up on our stupid
CDMA. Really? Yeah. Yeah. Um,
but just, I just, uh, when,
when it comes to these,
these fucking conversations,
they always seem so circular.
Like they never really go anywhere because
they're frustrating because you don't,
you don't really know what the hell
to do about this problem. That that's,
that's what's scary about
it. And that's, that's the biggest
threat is the growth of the state.
The real question is, does, does voting
really work anymore? And it voting.
Those are good questions. We've got a real
fucking problem. Really good question.
Because what you start to realize
there's not a major difference between
candidates. Is there, I mean, did
they, all of a sudden you go, well,
there's not a big difference.
People are disenfranchised. I mean,
people aren't voting,
uh,
young people aren't as angry or in
the streets because there's not a,
you can't really necessarily
make a difference.
Maybe that's how people have always felt.
I do think people felt that
way in the 60s, actually,
which is why they gotten to the streets
and they tried to make a lot of noise,
but that either I have the amount
of movement that we have today.
They didn't have the ability to do things.
And I's governments were taken
down with Facebook. I mean,
Facebook took down governments,
Twitter took down. Different ones are,
a lot of people are arguing and making
very good arguments like the Cato
Institute,
this Libertarian think tank about what,
that's why sometimes you
just say philosophically,
philosophically nobody wants people to
go hungry. And so philosophically though,
as government gets bigger,
more and more people will
start manipulating and
getting their hands into the
cookie jar. It doesn't do anybody
any good man. There's no way.
There's no way to stop that.
Once it gets to a certain size,
manageable governments should be
treated like a necessary evil,
not this massive socially social,
uh,
machine that engineer's
equality artificially.
It can't tell that never has been
able to do that. And it's not,
it shouldn't do that. Oh,
gross was at Obama's statement.
If you have a small business, you didn't
build up by herself. Well, exactly.
You know why? Because he's never run a
business and themselves that, that's my,
my knock on that guy.
Don't think he's a bad guy.
Don't think he's not a smart guy.
I don't think that guys,
I've lived in the real fucking world.
He was a community
organizer and an academic.
I don't want that guy running
running shit, you know? And if,
and if Romney wasn't so crazy
with his religion and stuff, I,
I would be like, well, he was
kind of a stud businessman,
but I don't even know what he stands for.
He hadn't come clean with the tax returns.
He's a fucking Mormon. He's a Mormon.
He's an old creep. He's a creep.
His wife was made out of plastic.
His whole family lives in the dark.
They're crazy
and he's just going to do whatever the
fuck they tell them. I always tell people,
if you want to know about Mitt Romney,
there's a video online where he gets
confronted by a guy in a wheelchair who
needs medical marijuana and Mitt Romney
shrugs this guy off like he does. Lisa,
of course,
I don't believe in medical marijuana and
he just gets away from the Jesus' robe.
But I will say that in,
in Massachusetts,
the guy actually spent a lot of time on
the other side of the aisle and got a
lot of shit done, including universal
healthcare and balancing the budget.
You can't take that away from him. And
by the way he was a stud. But you know,
Bain capital good and maybe create
a lot of jobs. I don't think that,
but I don't want to let the federal level,
I don't think you get them that kind of,
maybe not.
I think you can really be a real governor.
I don't think he can be a real president.
Uh, I think when it gets to that level,
when it comes to,
especially with things
like war government,
some have to do state governments
don't have to worry about war.
When you get to a federal level and
you're dealing with multibillion dollar
contracts and dealing with, you know, the
pullout of the truck from Afghanistan.
When I was telling you I talked to this,
my buddy who's a real CIA guy and,
and I had him do my podcasts and I called
him Mr Pink cause he just was like,
you know, it was really weird. He's so
smart and he's, he's really the real deal.
And I said, what do you get? Gimme
gimme some stuff about the Iraq war.
And then we went in there because
of this and that. And he goes, man,
he was like this. He was
like, yeah, I mean I guess you
could say that, but really,
you know what I think it
is. I go, what? He goes,
I think it's just a bunch of interests
that get together and it snowballs.
And before,
you know what a lot of people are gonna
make a lot of money on this notion and a
lot of people get an idea and somebody
picks up on it and they just assume it's
true.
And before you know it,
you got this fucking machine that
ain't going to stop for anybody.
And he was really kind of matter of
fact about it. And I was like, Geez,
this is an inside guy who
spent seven years there and
here he is telling me this.
He goes, he goes, listen
dude. He goes, it,
they spent $100,000 importing sand in so
that they could play volleyball in the
desert. You're like, Oh yeah,
we talked about this once
before. How much corruption,
how much waste there is.
And you know,
we've all heard of the $500 hammers and
all the stupid shit that you know were,
it was unknown accountability,
man. No accountability.
What's government? You know,
the idea that it's all tax money.
And what I saw with the banking industry,
I mean,
investment banks used to have to gamble
with their own money and then they
became public and all of a sudden
they're using your money to experiment.
And you had these cowboys who were like,
let's fucking leverage it 40 times.
I'm being simplistic. But that's
kind of what happened. Well,
Benny was talking the mathematician who,
uh,
the NSA guy was talking about other things
that the NSA had funded to try to do
the same thing. That didn't work,
that they spent billions of dollars,
billions of dollars, dollars of your
dollars, by the way that they don't.
That's the craziest thing about your
taxes. You pay whatever you pay.
20% of [inaudible] goes.
You don't even fucking get,
you can't even request it. You can't say,
hey, I would like to know, you know what?
How much of my money you're spending?
Is there a website I could go to?
Like maybe then I'll send it to you, but
you could go, oh, hey mister Callan. Yeah.
Well you paid $70,000 in taxes last
year and your money went to [inaudible],
you know? No, yeah, go fuck yourself.
They don't even make it up for you.
There's like, there's it. Just take it
youtube again. Besides it's Beeni guy,
also youtube,
Milton Friedman,
who wouldn't want to know about prize
for economics and just just youtube and
listen to his debates.
Just listen to those debates.
It's really easy to follow and all. He
talks about his personal liberty. They go,
you're a conservative, cause I don't like
that word. I'm, I'm, I believe in liberty.
So whatever I am, I'm very
liberal. It's weird when you,
when you go conservative
or liberal because people
like to attach themselves to
ideologies and they will find a,
like an area where they can operate in.
They feel more comfortable
being a liberal.
Then you feel more comfortable with
being a conservative and they just the,
they're there.
They don't have no openmindedness
and it just seems they're
on a team. Exactly, exactly.
They just lock on to team Mac.
I'm on team Pc.
I like android phones. I'm a windows
man. Marcel, we've got a windows phone.
Whereas whereas if you talk about liberty,
you're talking about a philosophy
and an idea that, that, that that's,
that's what I like to talk about.
I like having discussions based on the
ideas and philosophies, the underpinnings.
Not, not, don't, don't label me
Republican, Democrat, even a libertarian.
I want to talk about ideas and,
and,
and develop a philosophy that's
that fucking shit works there.
Can the conservative Liberal Shit works?
Look in works by the way,
with liberals just as bad.
It's what conservatives are.
Nothing drives me fucking nutty.
More than hypocritical liberals who talk
about Republicans being prejudice and
then they're completely prejudice.
He lost his mind.
Anybody who has any ideas
remotely different from there.
It's so weird.
That whole like artificial sensitivity.
You know like you, you've, you've,
you've adopted what is like a chic style,
a cool style of thinking.
You know, this is the,
this is aggressive style people.
We also,
my father was talking
about tyranny of language.
There's a tyranny of language
in this country where,
where one side will garner a sort of
a patent on. We are the progressive's.
We are, well, I haven't,
I believe I happen to believe we should
legalize gay marriage and drugs and a
lot of other things.
That makes me pretty progressive,
but at the same time I want a small
government so that I can be considered a
conservative as well because I want,
I don't want,
I don't want all these
vested interests in my flat,
but that's the question is how do you,
and if I start talking about,
if I start,
if I start talking about small government
people go, you're a republican. Well, no,
I'm not actually because I'm pro choice
and you know a lot of other things,
so don't call me and I'm not a Christian,
so let's relax with this stuff.
You know?
So,
so there is a tyranny of language in this
country and and there always has been
in political, in political
culture. You, you,
you did a really good book called don't
think of an elephant that I ever tell
you about this book. No, it's written
by David Frum who talks about,
I think his name is David Fromm. Forgive
me if it's not, but he talks about how,
how effective it is when you,
when you say this is the Patriot Act,
how do you vote against,
against the Patriot Act for example,
you're not going to vote him.
Get Dot.
You're not a patriot if you
vote against the Patriot Act,
and there are a lot of
things you can do as a,
as a political force to
hijack your position by making
it very inconvenient and
sound bad. When you vote against,
you can't vote against the page.
How do you change it, Joe? How
do you change it? I don't know,
I'm still trying to figure it out.
Uh,
the only thing that I can think is you
got to change young people and you've got
to have the people that are going into it.
Like this guy that we had,
David Seaman who was on a Monday, June
his twenties, 26 years old. Wow, that's,
that's the noise. I'm not
congress, the kind of guy and very
articulate, very bright. That's
the kind of guys you need.
You need young kids that are coming out
of college and that they understand the
way the world works a million times
better than some fucking dummy who grew up
in the land of books and crayons.
Okay.
Amos Oz is a famous Israeli
writer was saying, um,
he said the way you will beat,
they were talking about Hamas and I'm as
a terrorist organization and they said,
he said,
well I,
he had a problem with Israel going in
and assassinating Hamas leaders and he
said the way you, you, you
beat Hamas is not with guns.
Cause Hamas is an idea. And they
said, what are we doing? He said,
the way you beat a bad idea like
Hamas is with a better idea,
and that's a really powerful statement.
It is power come up and
remember that this country,
this country is an idea.
This eye is an ideal. And,
and in a lot of ways those men in those
founding fathers solve the political
problem.
The constitution is an amazing thing and
it's being jacked less than a reject,
but remember that it's a very powerful
idea and keep fighting for it.
Obama has done more to
harm the constitution than
any president before him.
What he's done by pass the National
Defense Authorization Act is nothing short
of what you should have considered as
treasonous w w w with someone in the past
we consider as treasonous the ability
to detain people with no warrant to the
ability to hold them with
no recourse whatsoever.
They don't have the right to a trial.
They don't have anything that we're
supposed to be standing for it.
America for foreign
enemies. Oh No, no, no, no,
no,
no.
It's for anyone that they deem
to be an enemy of the state. Wow.
National.
We were allowed to use that.
He has now rather allowed to
use the military to quell any,
did any dissent inside our brochure?
Yes.
Posse comitatus done. He's
trying to get through it. Oh,
it's past national defense
authorization act. Everybody passed it.
Obama said he was going to veto. It
didn't be taught. No one vetoed it.
No one pass it. I don't think
they get a say. I really don't.
I think when you've got a company like
Halliburton and then has fucking billions
of dollars and they're,
they're profiting in in mad
crazy ways from his fucking war.
I don't think anybody gets a say.
I think that influence the influence of
that money is so strong and so sharp.
They can't avoid it. I hope you're
wrong. I'm not wrong. I'm not wrong.
You may not be wrong and and so in
that case it's hard not to be sent.
How do you not know about this? We
talked about this before. I mean reading,
reading, reading this, this movie.
Just talking about reading this book.
I just keep talking to you.
Call that called the China
study is a classic example.
This guy does such an amazing job
of off Tang, what you're saying,
how we are no longer all of a
sudden your kid at school is,
is being fed all different kinds of food
that is not only making them sick but
fat.
How did you, but listen man, you can
give your kid food. Okay, that's,
that's a terrible thing and everything.
When your kids phone to school,
you can bring a lunch. That's not as
bad as what the fuck is happening.
The ability to have people
arrested with no recourse, man.
We are literally literally in a Soviet,
did I talk to you about this a while ago?
Man, National Defense Authorization Act.
It's a terrifying thing that was passed.
Terrifying.
All this shit that's going
on with wikileaks where
they're trying to pull this
guy out of the Ecuadorian
embassy in London. They're,
they're letting everybody know that
the rules are fake. Like, well,
that rule the world. He's actually
wanting for sexual assault and Sweden.
Sweden's just wanted for sexual assault.
Don't say that he's wanted for sexual
incident cries sex surprise sex is a
bitch. Shut it off. You can't turn
on a junkie kind of look up. No,
I was trying to look at that act.
Oh,
surprise sex is what he's wanted for. What
do you mean surprise sex? What's that?
Nearly had sex with a chick with a
condom on and they were sleeping in bed
together and with no condom he slipped
it in and there's photos of her hanging
out with him two days later,
like all palling around.
Look what he did was kind of creepy,
but guess what?
You're not supposed to sleep naked with
a guy if you don't want him to stick.
It was or, and that's just what dudes
do were gross rose, creepy animals.
Of course he's wanting to dive well,
it's not even that.
I don't know how many times back when
I'm back in the day, I'd be like, well,
I don't have any diseases. And
what about not just the tip,
all the dies? Well that's what he
did. He's a scumbag sex gambler,
but a lot of guys are, there's a video
of him dancing. Scott, myself. Yeah, guy.
Just regular guy is a video
of him dancing by himself.
It's just him on the dance floor getting
his groove on and it's so dorky and
creepy. You Watch and it's just like, oh
Jeez, look at this guy. He's so weird.
He's American, isn't the
American, how did he,
Swedish massage.
Yeah.
I don't think it's a man or a
fucking agent of this information.
You work for Fox and I'm just saying,
I think, I don't know. Well it's,
I want to see positive.
He's debates.
John O'reilly, Bill O'reilly,
and he does such a great job.
He fucking made fun of a Fox.
I'm such a good way though.
He just exposed and I read to a
bill O'Reilly. Oh he's Australian.
That's a stress. I knew he had something
going on. I might as well be American.
I was truly in Australia. You
do? Yeah. When went to Sydney.
They're fucking, they
have the, Australia is a,
they're like a little more relaxed than
us. A little more down to party little,
you know, this is fun people and they're
just different. I like Australia.
I've actually never met an
Australian who is a deck.
I had two friends that are really
famous in Australia and not famous here.
Orange Barker who's like Kinda does
well here. Eddie, if Eddie F yeah,
and both of them are fucking year,
especially orange are just
gigantic in Australia. Yeah man.
He's like fucking Justin
Bieber over there.
I can't walk down the street in Australia.
Yeah, and they love him in Australia,
but in America it's like
barely hanging on. You know,
he comes over here and just fucking half
fold crowds and doesn't make any sense.
He goes over there, he fills out
auditoriums every night. Really? Yeah.
He's sold out some crazy shit like
18 nights in a row in a theater there
at least it might be more than a
million, by the way. 18 nights Australia,
I'm coming,
it's like two months and offered a
couple of times and it's just like,
I'm always like, we're going to fly first
class. Well we don't have in the budget.
I'm like, fuck you. That budget,
that's a $25,000 fucking
ticket in first class.
That's why they put you on one of those
83 eighties and you get like a little
apartment.
That's what FirstClass says.
But if you don't do that then you're stuck
in a cramped spot for 16 hours and it
sucks.
Business class business,
cause I flew first class to Thailand and
I was doing a hangover too and that was,
that was that I got off the plane, I was
a year older and I was so fucking long.
It took me and I was sitting in first
class and it was like luxurious and
everything else. I had all tie
Taiwanese airline or whatever it was.
It was unbelievable, but you know what?
Too long and you feel like shit for,
you know,
they say that the radiation from those
planes when you're flying and high
altitude,
the radiation is way worse than the
radiation you're getting when you're going
through the metal detector.
Air is also shitty too.
Shit air and you've got to
drink a lot of water. I do that.
A lot of the hangover feeling the people
get dehydration, drink a lot of water,
eat something very nutritious.
Alpha brain helps a lot.
It's fantastic for jetlag.
Yeah.
Fantastic for jet lag and fantastic for
when you don't get enough sleep because
it's one of the,
one of the main reasons that you have
that sort of like a foggy misfiring sort
of a brain when you're hung
over or when you're jet lagged.
So your neurotransmission, Mike
Young said he goes, you and Rogan,
I've been with you guys on the road.
You guys don't need any sleep on the
how you doing? I was like, I need sleep,
but if I'm having a good time I can go.
I can go.
Cause I was in Afghanistan and I, I
didn't sleep for probably a week, like,
like just very little.
I was still working out.
I was just so pumped and
afraid at the same time.
So my adrenaline was just
literally pumping for a week,
so I didn't even need any say I'd wake
up two hours, I'd be like, all right,
we got sold out shows and you're going
to do a big giant fucking crowd's waiting
to see you. You get fired up, man. I don't
care if you're tired and you have to,
I felt sick with a fever.
I got on stage an hour and a half later
I come off and I'm like, I'm 100% right.
You feel better. Yeah. It's a,
no one is ever going to understand that
feeling unless they've actually done it.
But there's a giant responsibility that
you have after a while when people are
coming to see you.
You remember when you would go to
a comedy club and it was just like,
you happen to be headlining,
but nobody knew who the fuck you and I
went out on that stage in front of your
fans in Denver.
It was so loud at her.
My face feel that I could feel
the sound waves on my face.
That was 2000 ravenous fans,
ravenous fans.
And the minute I walked out there,
they thought it was Joe Rogan.
They were on their feet,
literally like, like
I was like, oh, okay. This is a, this
is a whole different level. Yeah.
We tell people what we're
talking about. We, uh, we,
we pumped the crowd and Brian went on,
we said Lazy and Joey Diaz brought me up,
but Brian went on stage
instead. So it was, it was, uh,
I have recorded it actually. Yeah.
It was really funny though. It was a,
it was hilarious because it like,
they went on for a little while,
but then they were like, Hey, wait,
what the fuck is going on here?
Hold on, let me see if
I go find it. You guys,
don't forget about the 10 minute podcast.
We're number 15. You're number 15 now.
Yeah.
10 minute podcasts number.
I think [inaudible] 15 and [inaudible]
last time I checked I was number 14. Oh,
you said that was mine. That was mine
yesterday. So it's pretty exciting.
Are you excited? I love it.
Yeah. This is you ready?
Brian's going to go out there.
Ask me.
You see how long it takes for
the realize to not me? Yeah.
Just come walking out
and this is Joey d is about to bring me on
what's going on? Gonna fucking
Frank's since what? I said,
they still think I'm you crazy or you
mean only people in the front row where
I'm like, what the fuck's
going on? They were like,
we lose a lot of weight. Does
Joe have rickets? There's still,
see he's still on stage.
And now I got onstage and then I was like,
okay.
Right. So your fans are great too.
They were literally all they, they all,
I couldn't get out of the foyer. You
hadn't seen it before. And I told her,
I remember telling you, I'm
like, wait till joy get Joey
Diaz goes on stage. I go,
you're going to see something
that you've never seen before.
And I remember the look on your
face. You were like, Holy Shit,
this is crazy. It's, it's a, it's on. Uh,
it's on a completely different level
when you see, did you ever think,
why do you think you're
a podcast is so insanely,
I dunno, um, people are connecting
with it. What are they connected with?
I am being as honest as
humanly possible and uh,
I have, uh, I got a lot of
interests. I'm fascinated by things.
And I think people get to be fascinated
and along with me on this podcast and
they know that if I'm telling you
something, whether I'm right or wrong,
it's because I truly honestly believe
it. Cause I looked at it, I studied it.
Even if it doesn't make any sense, like,
yeah, like big foot, like big foot talk,
I'm, I'm not willing to say the big
foot's not real. Yeah. You know,
and that's for a lot of people, like as
soon as you start saying shit like that,
you become an idiot.
You know, students, you,
as soon as you start saying things like,
you know,
you think maybe there
might be a intelligent life
that's visited this planet
thousands of years ago and made people
out of monkeys, like, get the fuck Outta
here. Yeah. I don't know. You don't know.
You're really,
don't just fact it.
People exist alone is
bizarre enough to me to,
to leave open a billion different
possibilities for how life is seated
throughout the universe,
including life on.
But I'm not afraid of looking
like a retard, you know? I'm just,
I think it's good. I think, yeah,
I think that's one of the reasons that
I also think that I'm really impressed
with. I think a lot of people, young man
especially want to learn something. Well,
a lot of young men are demonized and
we've got a real parking problem in this
country where we're
suppressing masculinity.
We're not accepting the fact
that men like manly shit.
We hundred percent like VHS.
We like steaks.
We'd like Leonard Skinner was
like hunting and fishing and MMA.
And guess what you being prejudice
about that is just as bad as a man being
sexist.
It's just as bad as a person being racist.
It's you're judging and making people,
you know,
many times I've felt bad for what I
look like or who I am or what I like.
When I was a young man,
especially women, intellectuals,
always different people would like look
down on you as if there was something
wrong with you,
that you legitimately enjoyed what
you enjoy without hurting anybody.
I always felt inappropriate and it's still
a lot of circles while come and I go,
man, I think in such a different way than
these fucking people. And I, I dunno.
It's just, I always, you
feel like you're like,
you feel like you're doing something wrong
when you're younger you're like, yeah,
I just like rolling around in
a matter. I like, you know,
well we're not represented.
We're not represented because men,
when they reach a certain point in time,
they have to put on a fucking tie and
some stupid shoes would slippery bottoms
and go to some job. That sucks.
That's the majority of men.
And so they're not really represented.
You know,
when a guy gets buck wild and lives
like Mike Tyson, he's not celebrated.
Oh that's good.
He's got a crash.
Well it's interesting because people
want to send to you right away cause I
think you're a threat.
I that that's almost like there was a
psychiatrist talking about male female
dynamics a lot of times and a lot of
women will be really attracted to an Alpha
male. And then what
happens is, and it's very,
very common and it's a big problem in
a relationship. What they'll do is,
and this guy's a couple's counselor who
works with a lot of different couples,
say what they'll do is women will then
be afraid that that aggression is going
to be turned on them and their
children. So they'll, they'll,
they'll take it out of the man when they
finally take it out of the man of man.
Cause I was like,
fuck this.
I don't want to deal with all of
these things are not attracted to him.
And I talked to him anymore.
Yeah, it's a, it's a grand game.
So the point is don't lose sight of who
you are and what you're trying to do.
There's,
there's a great deal to learn and
accomplish by embracing your masculinity.
You learn just as much trying to get
your black belt in Jujitsu as you do.
Getting a phd in,
in certain ways about yourself.
I'm talking about you learn
more, you learn more. Listen,
it's all relative.
But what's important in this
life is embrace what you enjoy.
And most men are not taught that.
Most are most men or they're made to feel
terrible about liking certain things.
And it's taught by the way,
it's just as masculine and play the flute.
If you play it really
well and no, but, but
I mean, you know, he's not
there. There are different,
there are different forms of and
expressions of masculinity. It's not,
doesn't even have to be hitting the bag
and shit, you know? Well, I just think he,
not even masculinity,
that's not even the word.
It's really honesty because I get a
lot of positive messages from women.
It's like you're allowed to be yourself.
Women should be in the group.
Like my wife's in all kinds of girly shit.
I don't even try to understand it.
I don't understand. I don't pretend, but
I don't judge her. I mean, she's well,
but she's,
she genuinely likes it.
There's people who genuinely like
country music, they genuinely like it.
They love it, they want to hear it.
There's nothing wrong with that man.
And the problem with a lot of people
and a lot of liberals especially,
is that they will mock what you love
if you don't like what they like.
They will try to marginalize your
opinion, you know? And you know,
they'll talk about calling you hyper
masculine that that's really interesting
why they marginalize your opinion and
they marginalize you and they do it
through criticism. And sometimes
it can be effective criticism, big,
very kind of glossy criticism where
they're using big words and, and they're,
they're comparing you to something and
you don't really have necessarily the
ammunition to fight back because
you're not as good with language.
And all of a sudden you feel kind of
without ammo might not even be that.
It might be that you haven't
even thought about it.
And they've been working on this argument
against who you are as a human being
or most of their life because you are
the type of person who's always rejected
them. You're the type of
person that didn't think they
were sexually attractive.
So it made them feel bad.
So now they've decided that these hype,
hyper masculine men who are not attracted
to me or assholes ruining this earth.
Meanwhile,
if that guy thought you were sexy and
you know he liked to fuck you and you
would like to fuck him and you were into
like this hyper masculine guy sticking
his big cock inside of you, then it
went out, you'd have a different thing.
It's like, well we think differently,
but as long as you respect my space,
I'll suck his cock. But no,
he doesn't want to fuck you.
So he's an enemy because he gives to
you a bad feeling of feeling of you not
being attractive,
a feeling of you being rejected.
It's the same thing with ugly men who
become woman haters their whole life.
They've been rejected by women
over and over and over again.
So they develop this, fuck these
bitches, fuck these hoes. They have this,
this attitude towards women
fucking lesbian, that fucking that.
That attitude is not much different
than the really homely, ultra, you know,
aggressive feminist woman who wants to
attack everything that men are into.
Hypermasculine rape supporters,
rape culture.
It's really a lot of the same thing.
It's finding someone who's different than
you and conveniently putting them in a
box. So that anything that they
enjoy, whether you enjoy it or not,
anything that they enjoy becomes
fodder and anything that they enjoy,
it becomes something that does,
that you can use to dismiss.
That kind of criticism becomes habitual
and it makes it impossible to actually
achieve anything in yourself.
When you,
when you walk around and like such a
good critic and you're a good critic,
that same could,
it comes back to criticize you when
you really try try to do something,
but you have to be able to look
at yourself and your own nonsense
and you also have to be able to look at
how other people are going to view your
own nonsense.
And just because you don't like
something doesn't mean something is bad,
you know,
it just means it's not for you and do,
you can't marginalize someone based on
what they like and what they don't like.
There's some brilliant people that like
fucking pop music, they are brilliant,
but they like to get in their car and
listen as stupid ass fucking songs and
sing along. It's fun for them and it
doesn't make them less of a human.
That's right.
We've got a real fucking problem in this
country of looking for fault in other
folks instead of first doing our own
goddamn personal inventory first,
get that shit out of the way.
First,
concentrate on all your own issues
because a lot of times the issues that you
have and other people really are a
reflection of how you view yourself when
you're around them.
Let me piggy back what you just said.
Cause a lot of times if somebody said,
um,
we live in a culture doesn't make
you feel good about yourself and,
and one of the things that um, that this
culture also does advertising things,
whatever it might be,
but we live in a culture that at that
gets you to think that there's something
you have to add,
you have to add to yourself when in fact
it's probably something you'd have to
delete. You have to take something
away from yourself that doesn't,
isn't really you and just get
back to who you really are.
It's a kind of a neat way of looking
at kind of development and growth.
I a lot of times I really think that
stand up and all the things I do are just
bringing me, bringing me back to
who I've always been in a way.
Like it's a process of sort
of, um, uh, distilling. Like I,
what I love about writing and
stand up is that as I do it,
I started to realize in some ways I've
always been writing about the same thing
over and over again.
But in a way I'm
distilling who I really am.
I'm getting to the core essence of
who I really am. So now what I do,
it's really,
you know,
at 45 now what I'm able to do is just sit
and let things come to me a little bit
more.
I don't have to reach as much or,
or I can just be and trust what's
inside of me to do the job well.
You also get to a point where you stop
trying to be someone else. That's huge.
That's so huge. It takes a while, man.
And be easy on yourself. You know,
don't be easy on yourself. Why?
What I mean by that is don't,
don't be too critical of yourself. Just
know it's a process. It's a process.
It's going to keep doing it. Don't
listen when it, it's going to be painful.
It's fuck. Be Very critical of yourself
or you're not going to get anywhere.
It's like you're going to be honest
with yourself. You want I us,
you and I were never critical
of each other. We were,
we were honest with each other.
Remember, very important all the way,
and we still are. We were, we would
call each other and we're like,
we have conversations where we're not
critical cause we love each other.
We're like, hey dude, let me
bring your attention to something.
You may not be seen, but you know
what? In both of our credit, you,
whatever you've done it to me
whenever I've done a deal, you're, oh,
you're always like, Yep, you're right.
Yeah. Thank you. Thank you very much.
I love it. When you do that are
important. It's huge. Let you look.
I welcome that, man. That's when
you know, you have a real friend.
When someone you calls and says, hey
dude, you can do better and this is why.
Or you know, you're not living
up to the dude at first. You
don't. You don't want to hear it and maybe
it will bug you for a couple of days.
It's beautiful.
Learn to learn to love that shit.
Don't take criticism from somebody who
does know what they're doing and don't
fucking just take blind cords and or,
or,
or people who want to humiliate you or
get better and be better than you with
their stupid words.
I'm not talking about that.
I'm talking about somebody who can,
who's on your side,
who wants to give you
constructive criticism. Embrace
that Shit, man. Embrace it.
Yeah.
It's just hard to find likeminded folks.
It's hard to find people that also have
their shit together or want to get their
shit together.
It's hard to find people who are also
like on the right track and not trying to
sabotage themselves all the time.
But I said before,
sometimes you might have to change your
gang magic changes people you work run
with. Well. That's why when you
and I first met, I would get,
I would get mad at these fucking idiots
you were hanging out with and there was
a difference between you and I say you
would suffer all these fools and I would
come along, especially when
I was young, when I was,
I mean we met when we were in our
20s I was a savage. You were a ball,
were a ball of hate and energy.
I just wasn't into no one's nonsense if
you are trying to loose nonsense on me.
Nope. Sorry Dude. And you'd see
it like this guy's a problem.
It's goes is nonsense. Just talking
nonsense. He wants too much tension.
You're going to hang out with him cause
I'm getting Outta here and that's the
only way to live.
You were so good at removing yourself
from any kind of suppressive energy. Dude.
You had guys around you
that were straight conmen.
It was really unfortunate
to see imposters yeah,
I would be around you and you would bring
these guys over like a party at your
house or something like that. Yeah.
Cause I have to look at cost manning.
It was fun. Look at this male hustler
he has hanging out at his house.
Like this guy could be doing anything.
You'll be a fake psychic Kiki's
fucking completely full of shit.
He's just decided that this
is going to be his thing, man.
It's La La so far that she's
so full of broken people
who does that? Who said, who said somebody
took the continental United States,
turn it on its side and everything.
Loose role to California. Well,
you think about what California is. It's
two things that are weird about it. One,
it's people that weren't
satisfied with the east coast.
Everybody landed on the east coast
and then here to reinvent themselves.
They can't,
they kept going.
They were willing to cross
the fucking rocky mountains.
So just that the beginning is just crazy.
The fact that anybody knew that
it was anything cool over here.
It's crazy to begin with that, you
know, the 20s they started doing.
I might just send a letter
though, man. I can, I'll take it.
I don't want it anymore. I
want some rain. I think, uh,
I like the winter here the best because
the winter, it rains all the time.
It rains like once a week. And
that's what we fucking need, man.
It's not natural to be living in a
place where it doesn't rain. And,
and when you really realize that
it's when there's fires. I mean,
there's all these fucking brush
fires in California every,
every couple of years or so.
There's a brush fire. Well,
you're not talking about moving
to Colorado. Dude, I'm down.
But Colorado just had
massive fires as well.
We had a big plot of land and built
some fucking credit. Credit village,
grow our own food, have pigs,
we can shoot from a chopper.
That's very important. Well,
the pig's really could get
out of hand when they're feral. We've
got to have a gym, Jujitsu Gym. Yes.
Rifle ranch, my pip podcast.
The tomorrow or the next day,
I'm going to be interviewing Nate,
Mark Court, uh, Strikeforce champion.
I'm looking forward to
that in Colorado. Yeah, no,
I'll be in Vegas this weekend at
the Paris. Ladies and gentlemen.
What's he's doing standing on and
is he training in Vegas? Uh, he's,
he's a coach on the ultimate fighter.
He is.
So I'm going to go in there
and meet the guys. Oh,
he's one of the assistant coaches
the country. Yeah, I think so.
Shane car when of course. Right?
Yeah. Oh, that makes sense. Yeah.
Colin and big country are eventually
gonna fight. Colin's got 'em man,
the poor guys had a lot of bad luck.
He just keeps getting these operations.
I was getting injured.
He had yeah,
back operation is how to get his nose
reconstructed and then he broke it in the
next fight.
Fucked it up again.
It's such a hard job and that's what
kills me about a lot of these guys don't
make enough money and they know it's
tough. Need to. What, what is, um,
uh, who do you think is the toughest
heavyweight in the world? Is a junior.
Junior is the champ and the,
until anybody beats junior,
you look at what junior
did to Cain Velasquez,
we'll get junior did to frank mir
juniors, a bad motherfucker. He's, he's,
he's a better boxer and
a really good boxer.
He's really hard to take down
and he's a really good MMA boxer.
And the difference between MMA,
boxing and boxing with big
gloves is that you can't,
you can't protect yourself the same way
with just like a high guard and blocking
things cause the gloves are small and
they can slip through openings and catch
her chin or catch her temple.
Whereas like you have the big gloves on
and you could pick off a lot more shots
and also an MMA boxing of course you have
to realize it with the smaller gloves
they can, they can, they can hit
you and do more damage as well.
There's less padding on the glove so
you can't take a shot that you might be
able to take with a, a bigger glove
margin for error is way slimmer.
You make one mistake and get clipped.
Right. You're done. So Juniors,
the best MMA boxer, you know, he's the
best at MMA boxing where it's like,
you know, Bladimir Klitschko would
probably fuck him up. It's regular boxer.
It's a different style. And
also, you know, dealing with
his, his footwork is
unbelievable. Oh yeah.
And that guy is always moving and hitting
the sand. You think you won that fight?
Um, I don't know. I
watched it and I lost it.
I can't make that call.
I think that at the end of the day,
what's his name was the champion.
You've got to take the
belt away from the chant.
They sent designation
decisively taken away. You know,
he mean Frankie lost to him
before that do close fight.
He's the toughest small man on
the planet. And I think that, uh,
I mean Ben hadn't been Henderson's since
a lot bigger than he is physically,
you know. Um, but, but that's par for
the course for Frankie Edgar. So I,
I don't know, man. I don't know enough
about fighting honestly to be able to say,
I don't know. He's going to go to one
45 now, apparently. But Frankie is,
he's got all that to contend with. Then
that scares me. Oh, hold on. All those
scary as fuck. I don't know what you
do with those leg kicks. It should be.
And his knees to his knees. He knocked
Chad Mendez. I would have named. He's a,
he's a fucking bad money cars.
Everyone in these weight class,
it's like the 55 45 and the 70 they're
just killers man for that matter. 85 yeah.
Well that's what the,
the whole sport is now.
What it's getting to be now is like
all these guys who have no weaknesses,
they have great take down the fence. They
have great stand up. They have great,
I mean all those worldclass in Jujitsu,
that's,
that's a word that gets tossed around a
lot. He's world class. He's a very high,
he,
I think he be called Cabrina.
He's beaten like really big name Jujitsu
guys in straight Jujitsu competitions
and his, his fucking standup game. This
was everybody's scared of, I mean it's,
it's amazing. Like when he got
Mike Brown, he got Mike Brown.
When he won the title,
he got Mike Brown on the,
on the ground and got us back in a
heartbeat and just battered him from that
position. But the way he got his back, I
was like, that is some high level shit.
Mike Brown is good.
Mike Brown is Mike Brown is also still
a strong shit that was telling me and I
know Mike,
you know,
and Mike came out to my stand up
actually in West Palm beach is great.
He's a great guy. He's a great
guy. And, and Mike, Mike,
I've talked to guys who've rolled with
might, they go, he's gorilla strong dude.
He goes, when you get on
you, you're not getting off.
You're not, you're not moving.
That guy is just a gorilla. He's strong
as fuck. And although took his back like,
like a ghost. Yeah. Although he
told me about that fight. It goes,
he said his hips were just so good cause
I tried to do shit in his hips were
like fucking, you know. Well
the thing there were, um,
a lot of people are concentrating on
his soccer players that there's uh,
another facet of a, of, of
like everyone has always said,
well wrestlers, it's supportive. You know,
wrestlers is a great base. And you know,
some people's like kickboxing, that's a
great base. But lately soccer players,
a lot of people are looking at soccer
players that eventually get into Jujitsu.
And kickboxing because they
have so much better movement.
Their movement like forward and backward,
they're there.
Their whole game is about jumping through
the air and running across a field and
dodging to the left and dodging to the
right and kicking a ball before anybody
else can kick it.
By the way,
they also learn how to kick because
if you've ever tried, try some time,
get her d one soccer player,
try to stop that ball and
watch how fast it comes from.
It's crazy and they know how to place it,
so they developed this leg dexterity.
That's why although has
that wicked leg kick,
his leg kick is so powerful,
man.
He just whips it around and slams
that fucking shin bone in your legs.
Your I favor about that.
He was like,
I thought I was going to
faint when he kicked me,
so I thought I was going to
literally faint. He said it
was crazy. Yeah, that's a,
that's another new sort of
a an entry point into MMA.
It was professional level soccer players,
which although was although was
like ready to go professional,
but there's that good.
Seems like MMA is more and
more gravitating toward
those that can be that our
master strikers, because in a way,
you've got two really good wrestlers,
they can kind of cancel
each other out after awhile.
Like all the more you wrestled in MMA,
it,
it doesn't necessarily pay off the way.
Spending time,
being an excellent striker,
understanding angles and all that
speed and all that seems to be,
because you can end the fight so quickly.
Yeah.
But you also have to have ticked
on defense. Yeah. You have to have,
if you don't have to take down defense,
the striking doesn't mean anything.
But it seems like if you have two really
good NCAA wrestlers or Olympic rusks,
they're gonna, they're gonna, it's gonna
be hard to take either one of them down.
So that's why they're going to stand
up now and see how well, you know,
a lot of the wrestlers they
develop, develop, uh, you know,
in St punching power too because they
learn how to throw themselves into a punch
to where they would throw themselves
into power double, you know,
like look at Dan Henderson like Dan
Henderson who was more of a Greco wrestler
or King Mo King Mo is a good example how
a motherfucker can punch and one of the
reasons why I could punch, cause he knows
how to throw his body into things. Yeah.
You know,
he's used to like putting the,
some serious horsepower into his double
legs and he puts that into his right
hand.
Now I'm Bob drops that shit on.
That's why when you see guys like John
Jones and Anderson and how they separate
themselves and GSP,
there are really extraordinary people.
There's just something about him. First
of all, John's very physically gifted.
Yeah. The distance of his limbs.
How tall is he? Six. Three.
But his limbs are, he's got
longer arms, maybe six, four,
but he's got longer arms than
semi Schulte. Who's a heavyweight.
It was the k one
heavyweight, uh, Grand Prix,
multiple time champion because
no one could get in on semi semi.
His arms and legs are so long
that everybody got fucked
up trying to get you on
me,
including guys like Badr Hari.
And he dropped them with like front
kicks to the body and shit is semi seven
feet tall. Well John has longer arms
than him and he's six foot four. Wow.
He's got a crazy Lao arms
and legs and the reach,
when we measure reach in MMA,
we only measure from the shoulder to the
hands, you know, to like the fingertips,
like how far you can touch.
But that's not real reach for him.
And maybe because you got to factor in
the legs and John's legs are so fucking
long, he can kick you from a place
where you can't even touch it.
I want to watch him fight shogun and he
looked like it just in a dick completely
different weight class. I've got
different human being and by the way,
he's only been striking for
four years. Shogun is, you know,
a long time and I may
champions is crazy gifted,
very gifted. He's a super athlete. He's
just one of those guys that he's like,
and it's the perfect storm of
being a smart guy. Being a guy,
works hard, who has good
coaching and is a great athlete.
All of them together and with, with crazy
physical attributes. You know, John,
every time you see him is better. You
know, you've seen him six months later,
he's way better fighter than he was
six months. I said, loves what he does.
It seems like he's just so enthusiastic.
And if that's the truth,
he should have taken the Chelsea
on and fight next weekend.
He passed on that fight on
eight days notice, which I,
I thought I could see his point of view,
but I would've if I was in his corner,
I want to say that you eat this,
you're going to beat this guy.
Like this is a guy who's coming up from
85 you're a way better fighter than him
and you gotta make it look
like a hero that you, you,
you accepted this fight on short notice.
And you get to silence Chael Sonnen Moods.
He's talking a lot of shit about you.
They just shut them down, beat his ass
and that's all done. You know, it's uh,
and it's an opportunity to
make some money, but he didn't,
he felt like it was too big of a change
to, to change up with eight days.
And it could've been also that chail
had been taunting him and so he didn't,
you know, didn't want to like, um,
also also there's, if, if it's also,
if you lose is if you win a big deal, you
know, he was supposed to, if he loses,
it's a big deal. Yeah. But
if he wins, it's still big.
You just still establishes himself as
a bad motherfucker and a scary dude.
This is what he is,
you know,
the way he shut down rampaged the way he
shut down were shod. The, we choked out.
Machida.
I mean,
I just don't see that Chels son and
being able to deal with that skillset,
I think chill.
If you had a full camp and really got a
chance to really bulk up to two oh five
for legit where he's, you know, then it
would be a different story that you know,
and I may, I may though, I'm just saying
that anything can happen in this sport,
right?
So as a fighter you're aware of that,
you know and you have to contend with
that directly and and emotionally and all
those rematch clause.
So you have a rematch clause so chill
submits them or something like that.
It's got a rematch clause and
the rematch is even bigger.
It'd be fucking gigantic.
I also think maybe maybe that card in
UFC seems to be very aggressive about
putting on a lot more events than
they used to and maybe they could,
maybe they could scale it back a
little bit and I don't think they can.
I think with fuel TV,
with responsibility for Fx,
yeah there's more demand.
There's is there though or is there,
is there more demand or is there just more
obligation because of their contracts?
That's that's good point.
Good point. But there is more,
there's not just obligations because
of the contract is obligations for the
amount of fighters that are under
contract for the UFC that you have to keep
working. You can't have a guy on
the contract and not having worked,
but once a year, fuck,
how's he going to survive?
Fighters have to fight at least two,
three times a year. I mean, and you don't,
you can't do that unless you
put it on a lot of events.
The UFC has more than 250
fighters under contract,
and I think it's more than that. And
that's a lot. That's a big responsibility.
People knocked in a white and stuff like
that, but that's a big responsibility.
He has to all those fighters and
now the WEC doesn't exist anymore.
So because the WEC doesn't exist anymore,
now we have all the 30 fives.
All the 45 to 50 fives had already
been assimilated a while back.
Why not? Because they couldn't
stay in business. The WEC. No,
they just figured it didn't make any
sense to keep the two of them together.
When you have guys like,
uh, like Donald Serone,
you have guys like Benson Henderson,
he's great fighters that
were fighting the WEC.
Now look pencillins since
the UFC champion now,
I mean obviously there's guys
weren't getting a shot at the top.
Can you see what Penson did when he
got there? He Won. Won The whole thing.
So the Benson being the WEC champion
and now and now being the UFC champion
really lends credence to the fact that,
you know,
it was a good move to bring those guys
in to incorporate them in those other,
it's actually, there's some really good
fighters over there. Mike Chandler,
it's really good. He's the lightweight
fighter. He's a, he beat any Alvarez.
There's also really fucking good.
Those two guys are both world
class and uh, and then there's, um,
what are you expecting more from the 85
or about Torah came over. Yeah. Yeah.
Hector Lombard. He was,
apparently he was hurt.
Apparently he had a cracked sternum. Oh
Wow. Yeah. And he fought anyway. He just,
he just didn't have anything about that.
So we had, it wasn't much he could do.
Yeah. Apparently he just didn't
have anything in the gas tank.
I'll tell you what though.
His fucking takedowns or ridiculous and
his take down defense was ridiculous and
they say it's five 10 he's five eight
he's five eight and down in American top
team I made a good study
and hand ball of hard rope.
I've never seen anything like it.
He's, he says he's as much easy.
He's an extreme mesomorph that's what
he is like. He's this thick and strong.
I looked at his legs at American top team
who's just training and I just looked
at his legs and I was like, he,
I mean Tiago others is my boy.
He's a thick guy.
He walks around at about two oh
five and he's about five eight okay.
Lombard is a lot bigger than he is.
Lumbars so ridiculous.
His judo skills are so sick that it's
take down the fence or ridiculous.
Tim Boetsch grabbed a hold
and he's like, nope, I'm in.
Bosch is a big guy coming down from
two oh five, he's a big one 80 fiver.
And you know the, when, when, when lumbar
wanted to take him down, he took him down,
grabbed him, clamped his arms together,
up in the air, boom. It's like,
but he just didn't do enough,
didn't do enough in lots of decision,
but he's still a scary
fuck. And I think, uh,
his next fight he's going to open up a
can on somebody's Anderson's next fight
is who knows?
There's a,
he actually offered to step in and fight
before he knew the card was canceled.
He heard that they were without a main
event. He said he's not an 85 pound shape,
but he can make two oh five. So he said,
I'll fight any two or five pounder.
And he wasn't even in shape,
like fighting,
fighting shit and talking about
fighting him. John Jones, no,
he wouldn't have fight Jon Jones because
he said he wasn't in shape to fight
that guy. But he said, I'll fight
any other two oh five pounder.
So if they could get an opponent for him,
some one 85 you know,
some two or five pounder wants to step up,
fight Machida,
they're out of the same house.
They won't find Machida,
but there's a lot of other guys at
two Oh five they could've put if,
if he had called up just to probably a
couple of days before they probably would
have done that, but they were
scrambling for him that we had.
That would be interesting. We
haven't seen Anderson. Yeah,
anybody at two Oh five for sure.
There's a lot of good fights at to Forrest
Griffin and what he did to a lot of
tools. I would like to see him
against like Glover Glover to share.
Glover is a the scariest for Jon Jones
at two Oh five and nobody even knows who
Glover is. Glover's on monster. Really?
Oh, he's a monster. Yeah, he's scary.
He's big.
He's about to 30 it cuts down to two oh
five but he doesn't have any weaknesses.
He's punching power is ridiculous. It's
got an iron chin. He's a black belt in.
Apparently he was training with
Leo Machida and rag doll in them.
That's the word. Yeah, but it's a
question also of his standup is not,
it's not just about punching power, it's
about angles and folk lover is a killer.
He is the one guy that is worldclass
that wasn't in the UFC until really
recently because he had a visa problem.
He couldn't fight in America six years
from Brazil and he finally got a fight in
the UFC and fuck Kyle Kingsbury and
just blew them out of the water.
I mean it was,
it was scary fight to watch,
but he's beaten a lot of high level guys.
He was the first guy to beat Soca.
Julie Knox. So could you out? He's, he's
beating the fuck out of a lot of guys.
You fucked up. Marvin Eastman
in Brazil. He's a beast man.
He's a scary, scary dude.
That fight is a fight that shogun turned
down show that they offered shogun
Glover to share and he said didn't
think it made any sense to them.
It's like this guy's like world class
and nobody knows who he is and Shogun
didn't want to find them. Shogun one up
fighting Brandon Vera instead, you know,
which was a great fight.
What a fucking crazy fight that was.
Hold on that incident. Oh shogun did. But
he had some tough times. It was Brandon.
Brandon put up a great fight. Brandon
was there. I think he was at the, uh,
I think he's taking pictures of people.
I think he was at the good looking kid.
Yeah, big guy. He was there.
Yeah, he was at the Denver.
He's really a nice guy taking pictures.
He's a great guy. He's a Greg.
He got a bad rap for a while.
He's a great dude. I love Brandon.
But that was a credible,
incredible fight.
But it's interesting that shogun was like,
you know,
one of those Glover to share a guy. Fuck
that. So you need to set up that fight.
That's like, that's a fight where
people need to know who Glover is first.
Cause this is like gotta be worth a lot
of money. This is a risky ass fight.
Glover is like the most unknown
guy at two oh five that's,
that's super top level and scary.
I would love to see him versus Jon Jones.
I think that be very interesting
cause Glover's is really seasoned.
Stryker really seasoned and tough as
fucking nails, but he's got to do it soon.
I think he's 32 now.
You know John is John's fucking sky.
You got, you got to handle it at
41 right? He's fucked up though.
His knees torn up now.
It's going to,
it's going to be a while
for him before he heals up.
I've talked to other wrestlers
about Henderson. They say there's,
there's wrestling strong and then
there's Dan Henderson strong. Oh,
he's an animal. They say it's the
strongest guy in the planet. Well,
his massage guy that used to work on
him said he's never massage degree.
He said he's made out of wood. So there's
never a massage like that. A dentist,
you know his massage therapist
now and she said the same thing.
She said she looks, she goes, what did it,
I think she said to his father, he goes,
what do you, what did you feed
him? He goes, I didn't feed him.
Just gave him a gun and talking about,
I'm on his own phone. There it is. Yeah.
He's always like, why don't we eat and the
stakes. I want to know I'm hungry. Yeah,
we will. The podcast is two
hours and 22 minutes old.
We just do a little more podcasting
and then we'll cut it loose. What?
I'm getting hungry. You're going
to go to Alaska. You gotta come on.
Come on with you. 100% how can I
say no to that? You can't say no.
I'm supposed to shoot out
a TV show my TV show my,
I'll find my opening and I'm coming. It's
five days. Yeah. You gotta go? Yeah. Fuck.
Whatever. It's stupid TV show. It is. I'll
come and see. Do you still doing that?
Death Valley thing got canceled on a
bummer. So fun. So act six people saw it,
but I loved it.
I was 16 I heard was 1616 people
good. Was it good? Was it a good idea?
I had one of the best times I've ever had.
I played,
I played a perverted police
chief and it was, and I,
they let me just improvise and do my own.
It was all like werewolves and,
and it was so much fun.
You called me up.
I remember you told me
how it was and I would,
I would hold a meeting about our
current werewolf or a vampire problem.
I just let it happen that we got
obsessed with vampires and werewolves
Zeitgeisty I know what it
is. What is that? There was
a theory. I don't know. Well,
I think in those kinds of things,
a lot of times technology starts moving
so quickly and we just, you know,
it's all technical and stuff and we
just want something. We want resets.
We want magic. We wanted, we, I think
being afraid though. Well first of all,
I think what happened with, with
vampires was there really sexy, I mean,
Brahms Stoker wrote Dracula in response
to the repressive Victorian age.
It was essentially a metaphor for how
repressive we were on the surface.
Yet how perverted we were underneath
and along comes as handsome as shit.
Guy Who comes in sucks your blood and
guess what? You you have an orgasm.
That's what those girls were doing.
He'd come in hand some shit
with a Cape and suck your blood.
Suck your neck. Do you remember the
Gary and it would be like, oh yeah,
the diversity was super sexual.
Yes, it was sexual. It always was.
It was a response to that
repressive Victorian age
where everybody was terrified
as syphilis and going to hell and at
the end of the day they were all fucking
each other. They'd be Yang and then
dresses up and just rail each as,
I shouldn't be doing this. I swear to
God. I go to church tomorrow. Well,
back then they used to put
dresses on legs of tables.
They didn't want people being
sexually excited by piano lay eggs.
They used to dress table legs. I
believe. You don't have to. It's a truth.
It's not a belief thing. It's
fucking craziness. People were nuts.
People have always been
in a lot of societies,
always been obsessed
with the sexual problem.
That's why men and women everywhere
are allowed to work together because no
matter what,
when you get Pete men and women together,
if shit happens the fuck.
That's why it's fascinating.
I've always been actually
most society so that history,
I've always been concerned and centered
around figuring out a way to to keep
that wall up. It's really interesting
to anyone. They do it with guilt work.
I do it with guilt. They make women feel
like slots if they're, if they have sex,
they make men feel guilty and
a lot of it had to do with,
a lot of times you get a bad disease man
that you before penicillin and now they
got none. They got gonorrhea,
a strain gunnery in Japan.
That is a antibiotic resistant. Aye
Yai, Yai, Yai, Yai. Fucking Japan. Oh,
fucking Japan man. Not yet. Wait
until the cure. Yeah, exactly.
What don't need to come up with another.
What is it about today though that
the vampires don't have vampire
characteristics?
It's like I was talking about
that movie Bourne legacy.
Did you see it? No. It's good fun moving,
but there's these is engineered super
killer who is constantly saving this hot
chick through this movie.
Constantly saving her. Yeah,
just carrying or jumping and throwing over
his shoulder, jumping of fucking Chaz.
Him with her never fucks her. And
I'm like, what is this nonsense?
She is weeping.
She's holding onto him vault alone.
They're alone in a house.
They're sleeping in the same room,
sailing a male fantasy. It's the
nonsense. You want to save a woman.
It's a girl fantasy, but it's the girl
fantasy because he doesn't fucker.
If it was a male fantasy B double
o seven he saves her Vinnie Foxer,
but this guy just saves,
doesn't know,
doesn't even kiss her at the end of the
movie after they've been through so much
together, they're looking at each other
eye to eye and smiling. That's ads.
No fucking, she doesn't pose cock couches
and starts talking to, what am I doing?
I shouldn't do this. I want them to love
and respect me, but I was cocky my mouth.
Now there's none of that. It's, but
that's the same thing with vampires.
He's vampires. They can go out in
the sun now and they just sparkle.
They just want to be with you.
They didn't want to kill you like they
eat deer blurb like what the fuck man,
that was. But that was the whole,
the reason twilight was so big,
he was an outsider. He was a
leper and, and, and you know, he,
she could only see him at night. It was
Romeo and Juliet. That's what it was.
But it wasn't Romeo and Juliet because
Romeo was 14 to this motherfucker's a
thousand years old. Okay.
He, she has a dilemma.
He writes several hundred
years old. Should I get turned
in? Be with them forever.
But she's a fucking high school kid.
What is wrong with him?
He's a creepy cocksucker I'll listen.
She was fucking cute.
It's all under clinical with that. And
he was in high school? No he wasn't. No,
he wasn't. [inaudible] was in high
school and the 18 hundreds no,
he goes taking science class.
He didn't,
he like is everyone died from like the
Spanish flu or something like that.
It was lines out, there was like the early
19 hundreds that guy was old as fuck.
That's ridiculous. And manual. The, again,
it's like top Herrera Dahmer was saying
dominoes that we were all hanging out
one time long time ago and never
these girls there. And Doug goes,
those girls good looking. And I
go, yeah, they're fucking 21 yeah.
And they look pretty good
from here. And he goes, no,
because at that age, you know,
a girl could have a goat head. I wouldn't
really give a fuck 21 with a goat head.
I'd be like, bad gut check with
it. God has got a really nice body.
It's fine for me. She's 21 you know. Well,
it's funny that the thing comparing the
way gay men look at men as compared to
the way women look at men and with women,
what's important is the guy's eyes
smile on his jaw line with men,
with gay men, they've gives, Jews
don't even have to have heads.
They just look at a body. If you could
find like a hot guy who was headless,
just stuck his fucking
hairy ass up in the air.
Guys would just be stroke and had
to be like, Yay. My Buddy, my buddy,
Kate's got a boyfriend,
his name is Stan and he wears his hair.
Everyone I did I tell you
this wrong. No, he didn't.
Filipinos really good look and he's got
this bubble ass and big tits and spoons
heads. Yeah, just, he does a lot
of bench, you know, he's like, oh,
he's got a full mouth. And my buddy
Keith is really my buddy Keith,
really macho and he makes
millions of dollars in a week.
He was like staring at him
one time when he was like,
look at him and then I'll
fucking beautiful this. And
I go, I was like, oh yeah.
And he goes, you know my, I put up with
all this bullshit. I go, why? He goes,
look at that. And I was like, but I
get it. I was like, you're not even,
you're not really even gay.
You're just a dude who fox guys,
I'm not even sure that's like,
you're just so hyper mail that you got to,
you know. Oh, that's still,
he's gay guys are just guys,
the guys sitting here. Listen
guy. All right guys smile.
A lot of guys are into the Asian guys.
That's where Asian guys
are like cherished.
Whereas like Asian guys have a hard time
when it comes to white women or white
women or like the flight went and saw.
I went with some of the
cast from the hangover.
I went to the fucking lady boy show in
Thailand. Let me explain something to you.
One day I'd last a day in jail
before I was banging the shit.
Those fucking dudes. One day I'd
last. I'd be like, you know what?
You look up. Fuck it. And the
butter. The mouth. Boop kids.
Well, yes. What if his gun cock?
You'd be able to look down. Look Dude,
just put a Napkin over or something.
They're tiny. Anyway, push.
What have you felt your bull as
you're fucking him in the ass.
Who felt his cock slapping against
your butthole? How many drinks?
Two drinks. I got to have at least
three do know. Otherwise it's gay.
She got to tell him, I said,
you got to hold onto your cargo.
I fucking the slapping me and he look
up bro Bro. Gimme some masking tape.
I'll tape it right to your
belly button and, and don't,
don't fucking look me in
the eye and we'll go to,
well how feminine did they look?
There's some of the best looking
women I've ever seen in my,
so the answer your fucking question.
Did they show their car?
Cause like what does it show?
They know they tape them down.
It's lady boys and let them
have had the operation already.
So then what are they then
look Brody Stevens, ask him,
he was being liquor at his face was being
stroked and I looked at Brody, I go,
listen broadly,
if you,
if you take that girl slash
guy home and fuck her tonight,
you're not gay and I'll defend
you to the fucking day you die.
Cause that's one of the best looking
chicks I've ever seen in my life.
And he was like, no, I care. But she
wears, look at it. I can't do that.
But they were fucking beautiful.
I a couple of months like,
that's a girl. There's no way that's
a guy. It's impossible at that a guy.
And they were like, that's a guy. Go,
we had one on the man show
that was so pretty that uh,
we were hanging out at the comedy
store and she was pulling up or he,
whatever you want to call her, was pulling
up in a car in Eddie Bravo was like,
whoa, check out this chick. That girl's
so pretty. I go, dude, that's a guy.
I was in Cheetahs. I was
a cheetahs in Vegas. Okay.
And that's a big strip club.
And I,
there was a girl there with the cowboy
hat who had a line of men trying to bring
her into the room to have a dance.
The reason I knew that that was
a guy was because on mad TV,
one of our makeup women,
what used to be a guy and,
and she was friends with this,
this person would become a woman.
So I knew that that was a
transsexual and she was also,
she was Vietnamese.
She was fucking gorgeous.
Then she later got married
to a very wealthy, um,
well I think I can say it, I don't
want to say it, but he, he was a very,
very well known rocker.
I'm a guitarist and a rockstar.
Oh,
rockstar. But he was a very, well,
he made a lot of money in a band,
very popular band.
And he married,
he married her and which only gave
me more respect for him. Okay.
Who is it? Come on. I
was, I don't want to say,
cause I actually know, I know,
but I don't want, I don't want to,
I don't want to say because I don't want,
I don't want them to know that
this person was stripping. I,
there's a lot of shit that goes on with
it. You know what I mean? I don't want to,
well,
this guy,
this guy that had become a girl that
Eddie Bravo had seen in the car,
we had her on the man show
and the man show was, uh,
the band show and they see
that sign behind is it said,
make me hard to see that this sign
right here, that was the game.
The game was making me hard.
And what it was was we had an
electronic box over a dude's Dick.
And we would decide when the light would
go off as a red light on it and the
light would indicate
that he has an erection.
So we would have like different
things in front of him,
like a midget eating a banana,
you know,
like all these different things
that would give him a boner. Yeah,
it was a fun Gig. Um,
when we, when we did it,
we did one of them with a transsexual
and she was fucking hot, man.
I'm telling you, you would not be able to
tell. So she's on this guy's lap. Okay.
And the guy's going to woo. They,
uh, she's got whipped cream.
She puts whip cream on her tits. He
sucks. The whipped cream offered tits.
Everybody's going fucking crazy.
The audience is going Shit House.
Then she pulls out her
panties and unveils this,
this dick that looks like it had been
poisoned because she Jameel hormones.
So Dick was like black and sick.
It was like,
it had been like it would've been
atrophying was, yeah. Oh yeah, for sure.
Not just atrophying. It was like it was
completely cut off from the process,
like withered away and see now I
have a boner. Is that weird black?
It was a black Dick and she wasn't black.
She was like a Latina something another.
Yeah, but her dick was, but the dark,
it was tired.
It was rotting.
It was like it was running away and she
pulls it out in front of everybody in
front of the crowd and the
collective of everyone and the real,
the look of repulsion in the guy's eyes.
Oh my God.
This tied to this chair with
this box over his dick with,
by the way,
the red lights flashing like crazy now
cause because we control the red light,
it wasn't really when you're in Florida,
so the lights, everyone's going,
Oh and here's a Dick Right in front of
his face and this crazy bitch that he had
just sucked. Whipped
cream offered tits. Yeah.
And now she's got this cock in
front of them. Yeah. By the way,
they had no problem with that.
Comedy central had no problem with that.
But they did have a problem with hard.
The reason why that sign is here is
because we had to use another sign because
he couldn't be make me hard cause making
me hard was they wanted to make me
stiff. Right. That's what they said.
That was one of the things they argue.
Those are arbitrary things that they,
standards and practices guys like decide
on Sunday the standards and practices.
It's the fucking, it's the network and
the advertisers. It's not even that.
It's just a bunch of dummies who want
to have their say on things. Right.
And that's why doing something on
the Internet, it's so beautiful.
Like if we had one of those
same executives in this
room and we were talking
about things, they would probably
tell us not to talk about it, right.
They would tell us a change of subject.
If someone had a sit down with us and
give us like a list of shit that we
couldn't take.
Personal responsibility.
It gives you your own sovereignty and
it's what all human beings want and should
have. If I don't pee right now, I'm
going to die. Don't die. Silver,
come to Vegas.
Two hours to 45 minutes.
Let's wrap this bitch up was
bringing this bitch into the,
into the harbor checkout.
Brian counts podcasts. What
is it called, ma'am? Thoughts.
Yeah, man. Thoughts with
Brian. Count. Brian Cowen
show. It's real simple. I know,
but you're going to fuck yourself.
I haven't some other name now.
I keep changing the name. That's, it was
stuck. It was sticking to this. It's good.
How about the Brian Killen experience? No,
it's the Joe Rogan experience. Too much.
Jimmy Hendrix.
I want Joe Rogan POW Bam.
This weekend,
Friday night now added Doug,
Stan hope a Friday and
Saturday it's going to be me,
Joey Diaz and Ari Shaffir Friday
night. Doug, Stan hope is joining me.
We're doing something for tosh 0.0
together on Friday during the day.
So when we're done with that,
we're going to do the show at the
Ice House that night and, and uh,
have a fucking party.
So we will have an ice house chronicles
on Friday that we'll have Doug Stanhope
go take your pants. Don't worry about
it. My brother 10 and a podcast. Yeah,
follow that and follow Brian Callen,
B r y a n c a l l e n on the Twitter.
Um, thank you everybody for uh, the uh,
the positive messages on Twitter and
on Facebook and even Google plus.
I've been on Google plus lately and um,
I've been on reddit lately
just for a little bit,
but I'm going to do a reddit ask me
anything before my specialist released,
which should be either at the end of
September or the beginning of October,
depending on when my website is done.
The new studio should be,
the lease is signed
tomorrow. Hip, hip, hurray.
And we will begin construction
and it will be dope.
And then we will take shit to the
next level. You mother fuckers,
it's going to be a hangout. It's going
to be like, like John Gotti Social Club,
but for Nice people. Um, but I'm,
I'm fucking pumped about it is I've
never really like had my own place before
and like a real place of my,
like an office and I'm a,
I've got grand plans for this.
I'm very, very excited and uh,
we've got a lot of cool guests coming up.
Survivor man,
I've been in contact with him.
He's coming on the podcast.
We're going to get a rich roll
who is a, um, uh, a Vegan athlete.
Mack Danziger.
I gotta Holler at you.
Well as also another Vegan athlete and
a great fighter and fights in the UFC.
So we've got to represent the vegans.
A lot of people think that I hate vegans.
I do not. Absolutely. And
I eat a lot of vegetables.
I eat a very vegetable diet,
but I,
I like meat and I ate that too.
Tough Shit. Most of grass fed though.
That's the way to go. All right, it's
fucking podcast is over. I'm Rambo Lan,
so come see us this weekend, this Friday
and Saturday night at the Ice House.
And again, Doug Stanhope
would be joining us on Friday,
but on Saturday it'll be Ari Shaffir,
Joe Diaz and me and a Ari Shaffir and
Joe Diaz will also be on the Friday night
show. Uh, next weekend, Santa
Barbara, the Lobero theater.
That's a next Friday night. Um, and
uh, I'm fucking pumped about that.
So that's a September 7th and
then Toronto on the toilet.
You Crest Theater in Sacramento.
September 14th. Macy hall,
Massey Hall rather in Toronto on
the 21st memorial hall and Raleigh,
North Carolina on the 28th and the
Thomas Wolfe Auditorium in Asheville,
North Carolina on the 29th. And Duncan
Trussell says, I may move there.
I may have to. And those, uh,
North Carolina dates will be dope.
Joe Diaz and Duncan
Trussell aren't you freaks.
Thanks to a Alienware for sponsoring
our podcast by providing us with cool
laptops. And thank you for
sponsoring so many MMA fighters. Uh,
follow Alienware MMA on Twitter please.
And thanks to [inaudible]
dot com that's o, n n I t.
Go get yourself some Alpha brain
or shroom tech or shroom tech,
immune shroom tech sport.
Get yourself some bones strong,
get yourself some new mood,
some kettle bells,
some battle ropes.
Get your manly shit on and use the
code name Rogan and save 10% off any
supplements cast. And we will, uh,
we will end this thing with Brian counts.
She'll lose but a ton.
So a bowl of Smith's fall,
I love everybody fits but expressive.
Ah, no hair on his head.
He's got big hands,
big feet trying to talk. Brian,
count into moving away. It was like,
all right you guys, we love you
and uh, this fucking shows over.
Thank you for everybody. Thank you for
everyone. Frankly, everybody, my friend,
thank you for your time. You'll give
you good to verse and a grow a pickles.
Grillo's pickles in the house.
All right,
we'll see you guys tomorrow
with Mike Birbiglia.
Mike Birbiglia will be joining
us in the podcast tomorrow and a,
and that's it for the week.
Alright. We love you. Fucks. See Ya.